RESPONSE TO A COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC- JUST LEADERS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE'S SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH ALL
MEMBERS WELL WITH THREE MEMBERS
PRESENT WERE EXPECTING TWO MORE
TO BE HERE SHORTLY TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL LISTENING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE ARE POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TO A
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. THAT'S
877-226-8189 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE. TWO EIGHT SEVEN
SIX ZERO FIVE NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECOMS TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS. PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE IN ORDER COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MOTOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WAITING. IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE. TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THE TIME YOU WILL BE
A MUTED. YOU'RE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK- YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I'LL DO MY BEST
TO MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED- FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE AS THE MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING. OUR TO THE USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
SO FIRST BEFORE WE- BEGIN
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE
FIRST IS FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
A. B. SEVEN ONE ZERO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. EDUARDO GARCIA
WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY ANYBODY
HERE. FOR AB SEVEN TEN WILL NOT
BE HEARD. IT WAS ON THE AGENDA
PENDING PASSAGE YESTERDAY BY.
BNP HOWEVER THE AUTHOR PULLED
THE BILL OR THE AUTHOR PUT THE
BILL OVER THEREFORE IT WILL NOT
BE. HEARD OUR COMMITTEE TODAY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SEVEN
ONE NINE BY THE ASSEMBLY AG
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THAT
LEAVES EIGHT BILLS REMAINING ON
OUR AGENDA. TWO OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT. SOCIALIST WE CAN MOVE
ON TO OUR AGENDA AFTER FIRST
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- CONCERTS
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER BARGES PRESIDENT WE'RE
JUST PRESENT HER TADO YOUR-
TOTAL HERE CABALLERO. EGGMAN
HERE EGGMAN HERE GLAZER. WE ARE
A POWERFUL QUORUM OF THREE GET
READY. ARE THE CONSOLE NOTES A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS IN
CONSENT CALENDAR TO BILLS ON
CONSENT OR FILE ITEMS FOR IN
SEVEN SB SIX TO THREE AND A.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT DO I HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL RIGHT THE CALENDAR HAS BEEN
MOVED- CONTROL CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THAT WAS A BY
CENTER EGGMAN. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTING OF FILE
ITEMS FOUR AND SEVEN AB SIX TWO
THREE AND EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
CENTER BORCHERS HI WE'RE JUST
OUTSIDE HER TADO HI TITLE II.
CABALLERO EGGMAN HI WHEN I
GLAZER. FORGIVE ME MY CONTACTS
AREN'T SO GOOD AND SOME OF THIS
WRITING IS A LITTLE SMALL.
SORRY WILL PUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL FOR THE
REMAINING COLLEAGUES. ARE
LET'S- ON NOW HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE YOUR CURRY YOU HAVE
TO BILLS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ITEMS WANTED TO A. B.
FOUR FIVE IN AB FIVE THREE
FIVE. CAN YOU PLEASE- BEGIN BY
PRESENTING YOUR BILL A. B. FOUR
FIVE. FRAZIER WILL IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. AB
FORTY FIVE CREATES A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK FOR INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA IN FOODS
BEVERAGES AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS. IT LIMITS HIM
PRODUCTS TO CONTINUE NO MORE
THAN THREE TENTHS OF A PERCENT
OF THC REQUIRES THAT HEMP
PRODUCERS BE SUBJECT TO TESTING
AND LABELING REQUIREMENTS. FOR
THEIR PRODUCTS. THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FEDERAL FARM
BILL CLARIFIED THAT INDUSTRIAL
HEMP AS AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT
IN REMOVED INGREDIENTS AND HELP
FROM THE FEDERAL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION SCHEDULES. THIS%
ACTION CLASSIFIED HAVE
INGREDIENTS AS JOINT SAFE FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION AND OPEN THE
DOORS FOR FARMERS TO CULTIVATE
INDUSTRIAL HEMP. AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA LEGALIZE CANNABIS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S POSITION THAT
CANNABIS IS ILLEGAL. IRONICALLY
WHILE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS MOVE BARRIERS TO THE LEGAL
TO THE LEGAL USE OF HEMP
DERIVED PRODUCTS. INCLUDING CBD
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT TAKEN A
SIMILAR APPROACH. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE
MANUFACTURING AND SALES OF
RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA PRODUCTS
INCLUDING FOOD AND DRINKS. YEAH
WHEN HIM IS THE SOURCE OF CBD
TO BE ADDED TO THE PRODUCTS IT
IS PROHIBITED. MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN PURCHASING HIM DRIVE CBD
PRODUCTS AT THEIR LOCAL NATURAL
FOOD STORES FITNESS CENTERS AND
EVEN HIGH END DEPARTMENT STORES
FOR SOME TIME. AND THESE
PRODUCTS ARE UNREGULATED. IN
FACT SENIORS ARE SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE POPULATION. ARE
CHOOSING TO USE HEMP CBD
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT WANT TO
VISIT THE MARIJUANA DISPENSARY.
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF CBD
DERIVED FROM HEMP IS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY. SHOULD THE CHANGE
SAID THAT SHOULD THE STATE
CHOOSE NOT TO CLARIFY THAT HEMP
CBD PRODUCTS ARE LEGAL AND FOR
SALE AND CONSUMPTION BUSINESSES
AND THE TAX REVENUES ARE LOST.
WE ESSENTIALLY HAVE THE WILD
WILD WEST FOR CBD PRODUCTS NOW
ONLINE AND IN STORES
UNWITTINGLY SELLING UNREGULATED
PRODUCTS. I DON'T WANT TO SEE
MY CONSTITUENTS BUYING UNTESTED
UNREGULATED OUT OF STATE FOR
FOREIGN PRODUCTS. THEY ARE
UNSAFE WELL OUR FARMERS AND
BUSINESSES LOSE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. WELL AB FORTY FIVE
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO ACCESS IT NANAK
INTOXICATING ALTERNATE
ALTERNATIVE PRODUCT. THAT
CONSUMERS WANT FOR FARMERS TO
ESTABLISH THEMSELVES IN A FAST
GROWING INDUSTRY. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY AROUND MARTIN AND
HE'S HERE WITH US THIS MORNING
FROM THE U. S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE
AND FOR ANY BERNACCHI WILL BE
ON THE TELEPHONE RIVERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL. ALL
RIGHT WELL NOW WHAT THANK YOU
HELLO TAKE TESTIMONY ON THE
BILL DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECH AND
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS. MAY
INSTITUTE- TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY IN OUR CASE EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED IN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME OF TWO MINUTES
PER PERSON FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR
FOR EACH SIDE. LIMIT- WILL BE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IGOR CURRIES. I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GO IN REVERSE ORDERS
FIRST WITNESS WILL BE MISTER
RAND- MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
U. S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE. WELCOME
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AROUND ONE ON BEHALF OF THE U.
S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE I WON'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME BECAUSE WE
HAD A ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT THIS
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO WHEN YOU
HEARD SB TWO THIRTY FIVE. MAYBE
FORTY FIVE IS VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL I WILL POINT OUT ONE
BIG CHANGE THAT WAS MADE TO THE
BILL'S SUBSEQUENT TO MY- TO.
BILLION OR A TO MOST WHEN I.
ARCHITECT WE HAVE A- OR OPEN
LAW. OKAY. AND HOPEFULLY THAT'S
BETTER. SECOND.
THIS IS WHEN WE
SHOULD HAVE ELEVATOR MUSIC IN
THE BACKGROUND. I HAVE BEEN
NOTICING. IN YOUR FANTASTIC
BAKER WILL ADD THAT TO YOUR
LIST OF TALENTS NO DOUBT ALL
RIGHT I THINK- LET'S MOVE AHEAD
AS APOLOGIZE FOR THE WAY NO
PROBLEM NO PROBLEM LOTS OF
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS THESE DAYS.
AS I WAS SAYING AB FORTY FIVE
IS VIRTUALLY THE SAME AS SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE ONE MAJOR CHANGE IT
WAS TAKEN TO TWO THIRTY FIVE
AND IS ALSO RECORD REFLECTED IN
AB FORTY FIVE THE FARM BUREAU
HAD EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS-
TWO MONTHS AGO WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS THAT HAS REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO
WE'RE PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
I'LL JUST SUMMARIZE REAL
QUICKLY THAT THERE'S THREE
OBJECTIVES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET TO WITH THIS BILL. NUMBER
ONE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PRODUCT IS LEGALLY ACCESSIBLE
BY CONSUMERS OF THEY'RE NOT
BUYING A KNOWN PRODUCT ONLINE
WHICH IS WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW-
IT PROVIDES A LOT OF CONSUMER
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
TESTING- AND LABEL WARNING
LABEL SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE GETTING-
IN A JUMPSTART AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
FRUITFUL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF
TAX REVENUE. BUT ALSO JOBS FROM
ONE INTO THE STATE TO THE OTHER
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS THAT THERE
ARE THREE THINGS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF
NUMBER ONE SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS WOULD LIKE TO SEE
CANNABIS LICENSEES IN THIS BILL
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT AS
WELL THAT IS AN ISSUE WE
CONTINUE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR. BUT
WE REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE
HAVING A ROOM ON BOARD WORKING
TOWARDS THAT GOAL INSTEAD
INSTEAD OF BEING DIVIDED OVER
THE ISSUE THAT WE ALL AGREE ON.
NUMBER TWO IS THAT THERE IS
TESTING PARITY VERY EXPLICIT
I'M IN THE BILL THAT WE HAVE TO
TEST TO THE SAME REQUIREMENTS
AS- AS CANNABIS CAN'T GET
ANYMORE TESTING PARITY THAN
THAT- AND NUMBER THREE IS THAT
WE ARE PROHIBITED AS CANNABIS
IN TERMS OF MAKING MEDICAL
CLAIMS- THAT PARKLAND
SUBSTANTIATED AND WE CAN BE
PULLED OFF OF US STORE SHELVES
IF WE IF WE SAY THINGS ARE NOT
MEDICALLY VALIDATED. SO WITH
THOSE THINGS SAID WE APPRECIATE
YOUR AIMAL SUPPORT TWO MONTHS
AGO WE HOPE WE CAN GET YOUR
SUPPORT {IN
BROWN THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN.
ALL RIGHT- MOVING TO- AT
ASSEMBLY. SO SO WITNESS- MISTER
AT EIGHTY UPPER NOT.
REPRESENTING HAND COUNTS. AYE
HE- ON THE CO HOST LINE
MICHIGAN WATER CAN YOU SEE IF
MR BERNANKE'S AVAILABLE. I AM
HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME WE ARE NOT
IN CLEAR. GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COMMITTEE- EDDIE BERNACCHI AMAP
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL A COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA BASED
CULTIVATORS- PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS AND DISTRIBUTORS-
YOU KNOW AB FORTY FIVE IS A
VERY VITAL MEASURE TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUED SUCCESS OF THE A
PEDESTRIAN CALIFORNIA- YOU THE
TRUE NEEDS FOR THE BILL- BECAME
APPARENT FOLLOWING THE ISSUANCE
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF-PUBLIC HEALTH. FAQ IN JULY OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN- THAT FAQ
PROHIBITED THE USE OF HEMP
DERIVED CANNABINOID SINCE
CONSTRUED TO BEVERAGES- AND SO
OUR INDUSTRY SIZE SERIOUS
CHILLING EFFECT. ACROSS EVERY
LEVEL ONCE THAT WAS ISSUED-
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
CULTIVATION WHICH LOST
SIGNIFICANT OUTLET FOR THEIR
BIOMASS- SO IT REALLY DAMAGE
THE FARMERS. OF HIM WHEN THAT I
THANK YOU WITH ISSUED- YOU THIS
MEASURE ALREADY AUTHORIZES THE
USE OF HIM CONSTRUED BEVERAGES-
BROUGHT INTO BETTER PRODUCTS-
IN DOING SO WILL CREATE
SIGNIFICANT PATH FORWARD. FOR
CALIFORNIA FARMERS TO EXPAND
INTO THE HEMP INDUSTRY- IN
ADDITION THE BILL CREATES A
REGULATORY STRUCTURE TO PROVIDE
YOU KNOW CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
RELATED TO HEMP. DERIVED
PRODUCTS- INCLUDING TESTING
LABELING AND HEARINGS TO THE
SHERMAN ACT- WHICH IS INCORRECT
AND THE- CURRENT GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICES UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- IN FINALLY YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE COUNCIL IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL- WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REASON AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY A
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY- THAT
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARITY ON
THE CONFORM TO FEDERAL LAW ON
THE CAP OF. POINT 3% THC AND
HEMP INPUTS PURSES THEY HAVE
RETAIL PRODUCT THEMSELVES- SO
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
THEM COUNCIL- ITS IT'S- AND
CULTIVATOR MEMBERS- AND WITH
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
FORTY FIVE ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL LET'S MOVE ON TO WITH
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM THREE
ONE NINE ONE. ANY WITNESSES
PLEASE APPROACH THE LECTERN.
ALL RIGHT- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES THE OVERFLOW ROOM
WHICH TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF AB.
FORTY FIVE. WE HAVE VIDEO OF.
ANY OVERFLOW. YEAH IN THE CITY
INDEPENDENT. I'M SORRY HERE TO
BE THE PLACE OKAY GOT IT OKAY.
WE CAN COME BACK- WHEN WE MOVE
ON A WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE A MODERATE VIEW PLEASE
PRODUCT ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR FIVE WE CAN BEGIN. THANK
YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR FIVE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PINE FORTY SIX DO
YOU HAVE A SUBMIT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANKS OVER TO LINE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
PETITION AND APPRECIATE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
AUTHORED SPONSORS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATE CAN YOU-
GIVE US AN IDEA HOW MANY FOLKS
ARE IN THE QUEUE AND SUPPORT.
YES MISTER TERRY ESSEX AND
KILL. ALL RIGHT KEEP GOING.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH AMANDA CORBETT
ON BEHALF OF CHARLOTTE'S WEB
WITH ENORMOUS THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO THE
LINE OF FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT WAS GERMAN THIS IS
ROBERT TO RECALL BEYOND TO
UNITED KINGDOM COMMERCIAL
WORKERS. PORTED TO MONITOR
SOMEONE ATTACKED AUTHORED HER
STAFF. THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY WORKING HARD
TO RESOLVE IS- ONE HAMPERS USED
TO PSYCHOACTIVE COMPONENTS OF
TEACHING. WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PRODUCTS ARE
TREATED THE SAME AS CANNABIS
PRODUCTS AS EVERYBODY KNOWS
THANK YOU CAN THIS INDUSTRY IS
VERY HIGHLY REGULATED THANK YOU
THANK YOU WERE ONLY ASKING FOR
NAME POSITION AND
IDENTIFICATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO ONE OF THE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I JUST KIND
OF WANTED AN EXTRA SECOND SINCE
THAT LAST WILL HAVE AN EXTRA
SECOND BECAUSE I THOUGHT I
REMEMBERED THIS BUT- BUT I
DON'T COOLEY NOW AND CAN I ASK.
I REQUEST. MA'AM I'M SORRY THIS
IS NOT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
TYPE OF EXCHANGE GONE JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION IDENTIFICATION.
WELL I THINK I SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE I TRUSTED CHARLOTTE
WHEN. I MOVE ON TO CHANGE MY
MIND PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT
TOTALING FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATOR CLINTON ACTUALLY WITH
THE ETHNIC VISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE KRONOS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE OF FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING DAVID
KING TANA WITH THE CANNABIS
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND THINK
OPTICAL WORK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR JOE TO
BIND WITH PLASMA VISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CANOPY GROWTH
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE WITH
AT THIS TIME THE FUTURE THANK
YOU AND HAVE A CONSULTING ON ON
WITH HER COLLEAGUES HERE. WHO
DID A VISUAL INSPECTION OF THE
OVERFLOW ROOM- IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY FIVE WE DID NOT HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS PRESENT SO THAT
SATISFIES THAT. ALL RIGHT-
MARIE ANY OTHER FOLKS ON THE
QUEUE WISH TO SPEAK
INDIVIDUALLY AND- ON THIS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MATTER. ONE
LAST CHECK. WHEN I WAS CHECKING
MY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
AB FORTY FIVE. AND WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SEVEN HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WERE NEVER GONNA
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE- WITH
THE OPPOSITION THERE'S ONE
LEAD. OPPOSITION WITNESS LIST
OF REVIEW FORTY FIVE- LYNN
SILVER M. D. REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE GETTING
IT RIGHT FROM THE START. DR
SILVER- IS ON THE COAST LINE
MODERATE CAN YOU- CONFIRM. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
SENATORS GOOD MORNING I'M
DOCUMENTS OVER PEDIATRICIANS
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT UCSF
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE. AB
FORTY FIVE W. STORAGE ERROR FOR
THE SIMPLEST OF REASONS WHO IS
WHO TO BE SAFE FOR OUR CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN FOR PREGNANT
WOMEN AND BABIES SHOULD NOT BE
ADULTERATED. KEEPING OUR FOOD
SUPPLY SAFER THE FUNDAMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF AGRICULTURAL
OVERSIGHT. ADDING
NEUROLOGICALLY ACTIVE
CANNABINOIDS TO FOOD WITH NO
SIDE EFFECTS AND DRUG
INTERACTIONS RATHER THAN JUST
THE GENERALLY RECOGNIZED STATE
FOR PARTS OF THE HEMP PLANT OR
THE ALLOWABLE IS A VERY BAD
IDEA. AB FORTY FIVE UNDERMINE
THE OBLIGATION OF GOVERNMENT TO
ASSURE SAFE AND UNADULTERATED
TRUTH AT. THE OPENING FOR THE
FDA REGULATIONS HAS BEEN THAT
APPROVED PHARMACEUTICALS CANNOT
BE ADDED TO FOOD OR SOME OF THE
SUPPLEMENTS YES THIS BILL
ALLOWS TO SUCH PHARMACEUTICAL
CBD ND THC BOTH REGISTERED
INTO FOOD SOLD AT THE CORNER
STORE. AB DE ITSELF CAN CAUSE
SOMNOLENCE SEDATION DIARRHEA
LIVER INJURY AND INTERACTS WITH
MANY MEDICATIONS INCLUDING
BLOOD THINNERS. TO MINISTERS
INTERSECTIONS DESCRIBE ALL THE
WAYS OF THE SPECIAL INTERESTS
BILL IMPERILS HELP IT ALLOWS
MORE THAN A LICENSED CANNABIS
EDIBLE PACKAGE OF. IN THE
CANNABIS HEMP ROOT BEER
PREVIOUSLY WITH EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLIGRAMS THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AMENDED BUT FAILED TO
FIX THIS PROBLEM WITH THE ADDED
LANGUAGE THE SURGEON GENERAL
WARNS THAT EXPOSURE TO CANNABIS
IN UTERO DURING CHILDHOOD OR
ADOLESCENCE INTERFERES WITH
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT. BUT WE DON'T
YET KNOW WHAT CANNABINOIDS
STRIDES OF SPECS AND HEMP
DIFFERS MOSTLY NGH C. ARE THESE
THE SNAPS YOU WANT YOUR
CHILDREN TO GRAB LUNCH BREAK.
FOOD SHOULD NOT REQUIRE LABEL
THING. DON'T EAT UNLESS YOU'RE
TWENTY ONE. IT IS NUMBER.
PLEASE BETWEEN REQUIRE AND NOW
NOT THIRTY. ALTERED GIVE PH TRY
CREATING. FRAMEWORK FIRST WITH
ANY YEARS YOU TO. WITHOUT THEIR-
ABOUT. BUT WHEN IT HE HE TO
LITTLE OF THE PART FOR. WOULD
OR TO CLOSE REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT SECRECY IN A- FROM
THE PUBLIC RECORD ACT AS
PROPOSED VISITORS PRESS. AB
FIVE DANGER UNDER WHO SAFETY
PLEASE PROTECTOR TO AND- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU DR
SO. ALL IT'S MOVE ON TO THE
ADDITIONAL UP WITH HE IN RE
THIRTY NINETY ONE. ANYONE
pAPPROACH THE LECTERN. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NONE- ANY WITNESSES IN
THE OVERFLOW ROOM MOVEMENT WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FORTY FIVE AND WE'VE GOT OUR
VISUALS UP EXCELLENT NO ONE
APPEARS TO BE THERE- MOVING ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE- SERVICE
MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. FORTY FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ABOUT-
ELEVEN IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I THOUGHT IT WAS A
REPORT EARLIER BUT I NEED TO
SWITCH OVER FOR NOW I'M SORRY
THIS IS THE ANDREA HEADSTRONG.
AND I TRIED TO SHOW TO THE
PEOPLE BUT I NEED A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION ON THIS BILL SO
FOR NOW I NEED TO BE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THIS HAS BEEN
STRONG I AM HONORED IF WE COULD
REMIND FOLKS TO- TO LIMIT
THEIR- COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME-
THERE- AFFILIATION IN THEIR
POSITION. THAT BE GREAT. THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS OUR
STUDENTS THROUGH I AM A
REGISTERED DIETITIAN AND NOT
POLITICS A FEW AT THE PUMP PUMP
INSTITUTE COMMENTING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. J. MEMBERS- MARVIN
PANETTA WHAT THE NAY KIND OF
DIDN'T ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL LOOKING
FORWARD TO MEETING WITH DOCTOR
TO DISCUSS THURMOND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO GO TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MCCARTY WITH CAPITAL COMPLIANCE
MANAGEMENT AND CALL US HAND IN
OPPOSITION THE MOST AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE SMOKABLE HOW FLOWER
RESTRICTION WHICH IS AN INSULT
IN INJURY CALIFORNIA FARMERS.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS LISA BROWN AND I'M A
RAW AND SMOKABLE HEMP FARMER.
AND I AM OPPOSED TO AB FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO THE LINE IS SIXTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JONATHAN FEDERAL AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE SAN FRANCISCO
CANNABIS RETAILERS LIKE TO PLUG
AND ASSEMBLES BOOKER WHICH ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ERIC GIBSON AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF STEEL AND OIL AND
OVER TEN THOUSAND ACRES OF
PRIVATE FARMLAND WHICH ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL-
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JEFFREY MICHAEL
**** I AM A GRADUATE STUDENT-
PC JANET AT UC DAVIS I AM
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF FORTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JOSHUA SCHNEIDER AND
I'M CALLING REPRESENTING THE
HEMP FARMERS KILLED CALIFORNIA
COALITION. YEAH WELL. I THINK
WE LOST YOU THANK YOU. BURKE
KEEP GONE PLEASE. OVER LINE OF-
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS CHRIS BOUCHER C. E.
O. OF FOREIGN KEY THE SEED
BREEDERS WE SELL OVER SEVENTY
FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN
COMPLETE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IT WAS CRAFTED WITHOUT
CALIFORNIA INFORMERS AND
INFLUENCED BY MARIJUANA AND
OUTSIDE LOBBYIST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND- MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GIVE
IT ONE LAST CHECK MODERATOR IF
ANYONE ON. WHICH IS TO- FIVE
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OR STATE
THEIR OPPOSITION THIS IS YOUR
LAST OPPORTUNITY WATER ONE LAST
CHECK. THANK YOU OPPOSITION FOR
AB FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN KILL ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- PART WOULD
NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK-
TO MEMBERS- SENATOR EGGMAN
THANK YOU THAT MISTER CHAIR I
THINK FOR BRING THIS FORWARD
WEEKEND HE SAID WE'VE SEEN
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE ALONG WITH
SENATOR ALAN. ON THIS IS A-
BEEN OUT THERE FOR A WHILE WE
NEED TO REGULATED AND WITHOUT I
WOULD MOVE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD LIKE
TO IN PERSON BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR FIVE A BUT I DO WANT
TO. THANK YOU AND YOURSELF AT
THE TOP OF THE SUGGESTIONS- TO
THE BILL. WITH RESPECT MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO
DECLINE TO ACCEPT THAT ONE THE
AMENDMENT- AT THIS TIME. THIS
SECTION IS THE IN WHICH THE DAY
FALLS IS BEING CONSIDERED FOR
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS. I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ALL THOSE CHANGES
AT THE SAME TIME IN THE IN THE
FUTURE COMMITTEE. SO I HOPE
YOU'LL ACCEPT THAT. AND I DO
WANT TO SPEAK A COMMON AYE
OVER. ONE OF THE OPPOSITION WAS
ABOUT SMOKEABLE. THIS WILL LET
YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPONENTS ON THE BILL
SO I APPRECIATE THE AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU AND YOUR
CERTAINLY WOMAN OF YOUR WORD-
AND THOSE ISSUES WILL BE DEALT
WITH AT THE NEXT STAGE. SO WE
HAVE A THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER EGGMAN IN THE MOTION
WOULD BE TO PASS BUT FIRST. BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. COKIE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR OUR
SERVER AB FORTY FIVE DO PASSED
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CENTREBOARD. FIVE WE'RE JUST
TIED HER TONGUE. COPYRIGHT
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT THE
BILL ON CALL. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IGOR CURRY'S BACK AGAIN
AND PROCEEDING WITH THEIR
SECOND BILL FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB FIVE THREE FIVE. AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK FEEDBACK ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL
ESPECIALLY FOR ALL THE EFFORTS
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF. I WANT
TO ALSO THINK MADAM VICE CHAIR
AND SENATOR EGGMAN FOR YOUR CO
AUTHOR STRIP ON THIS BILL.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES COMPANIES
TO LABEL THE BOTTLES OF
CALIFORNIANS TO BE A 100%
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL. HOWEVER
FROM OUT OF STATE INTERESTS
HAVE BEGUN PURCHASING BROWN'S
WHOSE NAMES INCLUDE CALIFORNIA
ORREGIONAL NAMES AND BLENDING
THOSE OILS WITH INTERNATIONAL
OILS. THE WORST PRACTITIONERS
ARE MARKING THEMSELVES OF
CALIFORNIA GROWN AND USING AS
LITTLE AS 14% OF CALIFORNIA ALL
BOILS IN THEIR PLANS. CHEAPER
INTERNATIONAL ALL OF UNDER CUT
CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND BRANDS
MUST ADHERE TO THE HIGHEST AND
MOST EXPENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
LABOR AND CONSUMER STANDARDS IN
THE WORLD. YOU KNOW MEMBERS WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR
FAMILY FARMERS IN THIS CAPITAL
BUT FRANKLY. WE DON'T DO A
WHOLE LOT TO PROTECT THEM IN
THE MARKET PLACE. SENATORS THIS
IS OUR CHANCE TO SHOW THAT
WHILE WE ASK A LOT WILL FIGHT
FOR THEM AND WILL ENSURE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA BRAND IS
PROTECTED AND CONSUMERS KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR IT WHEN
I BRAG CALLS HIMSELF CALIFORNIA.
THE AMENDMENT FIVE TAKE IT
TAKEN- I'VE TAKEN RESPOND TO
EVERY CONCERN YOU HAVE
EXPRESSED TO ME. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR OUR VOTE. WITH ME TODAY
IS- LOUIS BROWN TO CALL LUCIEN
COALITION OF TRUTH IN ALL OF
OUR LABELING. AND CAROLINE
BEALE HUNTER ON BEHALF OF YOUR
TODAY HE WENT TO NATION THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- THE FIRST WITNESS WITH
NINE WILL BE LOUIS BROWN. AND
THIS. WITNESS WILL BE CAROLINE
BEALE HUNTER ON BEHALF OF YOUR
AGENT DALE WINTON NATION. AND I
BELIEVE SHE'LL BE ON THE
COASTLINE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME SO MISTER BROWN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRIDGE THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN TODAY ON BEHALF
THAT THE COALITION FOR TRUTH IN
ALL OF OIL LABELING. I WANT TO.
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
CHAIR AND STAFF THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
IMPOTANT ISSUE- AS YOU KNOW
AND OTHERS KNOW- THERE'S NO
OTHER FOOD PRODUCTS THAT'S MORE
ADULTERATED IN THE WORLDWIDE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE SPACE AS
ALL OF WHAT. SO THE CALIFORNIA
OLIVE OIL INDUSTRY FOR DECADES
NOW HAVE REALLY GONE ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO TRY TO SET ITSELF
APART. FROM THIS ADULTERATION
THAT TAKES PLACE- BY CREATING
THAT BRAND OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF
WELL WE HAVE SOME THE MOST
STRICT STANDARDS IN THE WORLD
WHEN IT COMES TO QUALITY FOR
OUR CALIFORNIA ALL OF WILL WE
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT- THAT- IN STATE LAW AS
WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO DO SINCE.
THE NINETEEN FORTIES WHEN WE'VE
REALLY MADE IT THE LAW TO
MISBRANDED OLIVE OIL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH
YOUR HELP AND HELP THE
COMMITTEE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL NOW TRULY FOCUSES ON TRUTH
IN LABELING- AND GIVES
CONSUMERS THE DISCLOSURE THAT
THEY NEED. AND THAT THEY ARE
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING THESE PURCHASES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
THAT BY CALIFORNIA ALL WILL
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GETTING
CALIFORNIA OFF WELL SO WITH
THAT. WE SUPPORT THE BILL ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND EXPRESS OUR
APRECIATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR MODERATOR DO WE HAVE-
CAROLINE BEALE. HUNTER ALL ON
THE LINE. I DO NOT SEE THAT SHE
IS CONNECTED BUT IF YOU ARE
CONNECT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. IF YOU WERE ON THE
LINE. IF SHE'S NOT THERE BUT
DOES NOT APPEAR AT OR IF SHE
COMES IN THE QUEUE- THEN WILL-
WE'LL GO WE'LL WE'LL GO BACK TO
HER- ANY OF THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS- WISHING. TO OFFER
SUPPORT ALL I HEAR AND ROOM
THREE ONE NINE ONE. PLEASE
APPROACH SELECT TURN. SEEING
NONE- ANY WITNESSES IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM WHICH TESTIFIED
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE FIVE.
IT IS OVERFLOWING IN THE
OVERFLOW. ALL RIGHT- LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATORDO WE HAVE ANY FOLKS
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE
FIVE ON THE LINE AND IF SO IF
YOU CAN GIVE US A SENSE HOW
MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THREE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN THEY'RE
OFFERING SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THREE FIVE. AND IT LOOKS LIKE
WE AREGOING TO HAVE TO IN Q.
THREE AND Q. EXCUSE ME. AND WE
WILL CUT THE LINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BRUNTON COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THAT WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MAKAYLA DINNER ON
YOUR BAND ALL IN AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE YELLOW COUNTY
YOUNG FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
GENNEM IMPORTED EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
GO TO LINE OF FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD JOB WITH THE ALL
OF OUR COMMISSION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
M. MODERATE WE HAVE ANY OTHER
FOLKS ON THE LINE. IN SUPPORT
NOW AS A REMINDER IF SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE THREE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FOR THIS IMPORTANT YOU
AT THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OR HAVE YOU HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS ONE AWFUL THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR ME ANY
OPPOSITION. THERE APPEARS TO BE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION- WITNESS
LISTED FOR AB FIVE THREE FIVE
ANY FOLKS HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. WISHING TO
SPEAK. HI I APOLOGIZE. GERMAN
FOR THE CONFUSION- WHEN THEY
GOT. SICK SHIFTED INSTEAD TO
SELL ME ON A ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ALL OVER IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL BRANCHES YOU
KNOW. THE LEADING GROWER AND
PROCESSOR OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF.
THE FIFTY OVER FIFTY FAMILY
FARMERS. WE HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH AN- AD AND PURCHASED-
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL FROM. THAT
HAVE BEEN A LEADING- PONANT OF
THE STANDARDS AND THE
COMMISSION FOR YEARS SO WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA ALL RETREAT THANK
THE CHAIR FOR YOUR FOCUS AND
SKILL AND BRING THE PARTIES
TOGETHER FOR AN ACCEPTABLE
OUTCOME THE CONSULTANT HER
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND STAFF FOR
LISTENING TO CONCERNS IN
AMENDING THE PROPOSAL TO ASSIST
CONSUMERS AND PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY CALIFORNIA ALL OF
LANCE'S IS WE DISCUSSED OUR
COULD COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPARENCY BUT THINK THIS IT
ADDS ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY
BOB WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
WITH THE ADDITIONAL SENSOR WAS
ADDED INTO. TWO OF SECTION D.
BY THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL THAT
STARTS TO PRESCRIBE EXACTLY HOW
CONTAINS AN AND THE DESCRIPTION
WILL BE PLACED ON THE FRONT OF
THE LABEL AGAIN WE'VE AGREED TO
FIRST PUT ON THE FRONT LABEL AT
THE SAME SIZE AS THE GUINEA
TERMA CALIFORNIA AND THAT WOULD
BE PERCENT CALIFORNIA AND SO WE
WOULD REQUEST THAT IT BE
REMOVED AND WHEN THAT YES WE
WILL. BE REMOVE OPPOSITION TO
GO TO NEUTRAL. YOUR TIME AND
WORK ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ARE ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION- HERE IN
THIS ROOM. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
TO OVERFLOW- REGARDING AB FIVE
THREE FIVE. ONCE AGAIN
OVERWHELMING- MOVING ON TO
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATE
DO WE HAVE ANY FOLKS- ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE
THREE FIVE AND IF YOU CAN GIVE
US A SENSE OF FAMILY IN THE
QUEUE THAT BE GREAT. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE IN A POSITION OF AB
FIVE THREE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FIVE THREE FIVE. AND WE HAVE TO
IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER THEIR NUMBERS. THREE
MINDER WE ARE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. FIVE THREE FIVE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE ANDREA
HELPED FROM OPPOSED MAYBE YOU
SHOULD FIX THE HOMELESS ISSUE
INSTEAD OF HAGGLING. THANK ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU REMINDER WE ARE
ASKING FOR NAME OPPOSITION AN
AFFILIATION THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M READY ON
BEHALF OF STONEWALL KITCHEN
WITH BASED METHODS WERE MOVING
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION WE WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL AS YOUR WORK WITH US. ALL
RIGHTS MODERATE KING PUTS YOUR
ONE LAST CHECK FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF FIVE THREE FIVE BEFORE BRING
IT BACK THANK YOU TO DAIS.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE THREE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TERM
MEMBERS APOLOGIES I'M I'M
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT
CAITLYN JOHNSON WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS. ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. ARE YOU A MOCKERY
HAVE LITTLE. ALL RIGHT LOOK NO
FURTHER IF YOU. ALL RIGHTS ARE
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS DO WE
HAVE. CENTER EGGMAN THANK YOU-
THANK YOU FOR WORKING ON THIS I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR A WHILE YOU KNOW I
HAVE A FRIEND WHO. WAY BACK IN
THE MILITARY WE'RE STILL
FRIENDS AND SHE'S AT THE
STATION IN SPAIN AND FELL IN
LOVE WITH ALL OF US. AND ALWAYS
HAD A DREAM OF GETTING A LITTLE
ALL OF RANCHO SHE HAS ALL THREE
ACRES OUT IN VALLEY SPRINGS AND
I WAS TELLING HER ABOUT THIS
BILL AND SHE WAS OUTRAGE I HAD
NO IDEA THE CALIFORNIA OLIVE
RANCH WE'RE NOT ALL 100%
CALIFORNIA GROWN AND I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THAT WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT. AND I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS. IT AS I AS I READ IT SEEMS
NOW THAT THAT EVERYBODY'S GOING
TO HAVE TO CHANGE A LABEL TO BE
ABLE TO PUT THE PERCENTAGE. OF
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL AND IT IS
NOT. GOING TO CREATE A PROBLEM
FOR THE INDUSTRY OF EVERYONE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE A LABEL
OR IF IT IS A HUNDRED PERCENT.
ALL OF OIL CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT
HAVE TO THEN. REDO YOUR LABEL
TO PUT THAT ON. IF IT'S A 100%
THE CALIFORNIA ALL OF WORLD.
THERE'S A LABEL ALREADY ON THIS
THIS IS A 100% CALIFORNIA ALL
OF THIS IS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THE CONSUMER. HAS THE ABILITY
TO VISUALLY LOOK AT IT VERY
EASILY WHEN IT'S ON THE SHELF.
WHAT IF WHAT IT IS THAT HAS
BEEN KNOWN THAT SOME. BUT DO
OTHER BLENDS. AND IT MIGHT BE
ONLY UP 214% OF CALIFORNIA ALL
OF WILL AND SO I THINK IT'S
MISLEADING- QUITE FRANKLY YOU
KNOW ME I MEAN THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION MAKING SURE THAT
THEY GET THE RIGHT THINGS THAT
THEY'RE PURCHASING. AND I
PROTECT OUR SMALL FOR OUR-
FARMERS SO. THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. THANK WITH THAT
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. SENATOR GLAZERS. I WILL
FIRST- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR- REALLY TRYING TO
PROTECT THE BRAND- THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO US YEARS
CALIFORNIA BEYOND OLIVE OIL-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SET SUCH
INCREDIBLE COMMODITIES AND-
WONDERFULLY FARMED AND- AT THE
HIGHEST QUALITY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
TRYING TO. DO THAT IN THIS BILL
AND I KNOW IT'S OF A GOAL OF
OURS TO DO THAT A LOT OF OTHER
SPACES HERE- I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR WORKING ON
ON THIS BILL AND TRYING TO FIND
COMPETITION- ALONG WITH THE
AUTHOR I THINK THAT THEY'VE
COME A LONG WAY IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY. I DID
WANT TO ASK IN AND MAYBE. IT
MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE TO THE
CHAIR BUT YOU CAN STILL
INDICATE TO WALK THROUGH THIS
THIS FINAL LAST WORDING ISSUE
BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE CONFUSING
TO ME I'M- I'M LOOKING AT THE
BILL. I'M LOOKING ON PAGE FOUR-
LINE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
I SEE WHAT'S THERE AND I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED AS TO WHAT'S
ALLEGED COUNCIL LANGUAGE IF
THERE'S INJECTION TO END AND.
IF YOU COULD CLARIFY THAT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR ME.
SPECIFICITY. WELL I DON'T. IS
NOT WORKING SO WELL. YEAH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU WISH TO
ADD TO THE ELEMENT THEY HAVE
THE PERCENT SHALL BE DECLARED
BY THE WORDS CONTAINING OR
CONTAINS PERCENT I LOVE TO
BLANK CALIFORNIA ALL OF WELL
PERCENT THAT WAS A PIECE WAS
LEFT IN THERE WHAT WHAT'S THE
OBJECTION THAT THAT'S BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THIS LANGUAGE.
YOUR BORDERS YOU HAVE WITH THE
STATE CALIFORNIA THAT THEY HAVE
TO SHOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGES. I
THINK IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL IF WE
HAD- ONE OF THE- ON PRINCIPLES
ALL RIGHT IN OPPOSITION- SAY
THAT MORE CLEARLY. THANK YOU.
SO WE'VE SO WE'VE AGREED FULLY
TO THE FRONT OF THE BACK LABEL
IN A PERCENT CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE LINE UP AND
DO THAT THE FIRST SENTENCE THE
SECOND SENTENCE THEM THEN.
LET'S COUNCIL MY UNDERSTANDING
TALKING WITH THE CONSULTANT
SIDE TO FURTHER EXPLAIN THAT.
AND SO IT REQUIRES THE WORD
CONTAINS ARE CONTAINING AND
THEN THE ADDITIONAL WORDS ALL
OF OIL. SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
IT'S JUST PRESCRIPTIVE AND THIS
WILL HAVE TO BE IN THE SAME
EXACT SIZE. AS THE LARGEST THE
GOVERNMENT NOT JUST TO TURN
CALIFORNIA WHICH AGAIN AND THE
PERCENTAGE WE FULLY ACCEPT
THAT. AND THEN THAT'S THAT WAS
THE AGREEMENT WHAT'S THAT
AGREEMENT WENT TO ALLEGE
COUNCIL THEY ADDED IN THIS
FURTHER CLARIFICATION THE YOU
WOULD NEED TO USE THE TERMS
CONTAINS ARE CONTAINING. AND
THEN THE DOCTOR THE ALL WHEEL
IN THE SAME FOUGHT IN THAT AREA
WE WILL OBVIOUSLY WE PROTECT
VIRGIN ON ON OUR ON OUR LABELS
EXTRA VIRGIN OLIVE OIL IS THE-
IS THE LARGEST STATEMENT. ON
THAT I MEAN THAT THAT'S THAT'S
A PROMOTION BUT WHEN YOU GET
OUT OF THIS FURTHER
CLARIFICATION OF THE TERMS
CONTAINS OKAY AND ALL OF OIL IT
WOULD WOULD COME OUT AND THEN
WE COULD LABEL JUST PERCENT
CALIFORNIA'S LATEST BABY NOT
QUESTION THE CONSOLE BECAUSE IT
SEEMS IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL GIVES YOU OPTIONS THERE.
IT HAS THE WORD. IS THAT
CORRECT THAT THAT BILL PROOF
THAT THIS PROPOSED. I THINK IT
IS LINES IT HAS IT BUT THE WAY
THE BILL IS WRITTEN IT SAYS
THAT THAT SHOULD BE DECLARED BY
THE WORDS CONTAINING OR
CONTAINS LIKE PERCENT
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL. OR IT
WOULD SAY LIKE 10% CALIFORNIA
ALL. AND SO I THINK THE CONCERN
WAS THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE TO
WORRY WHEN IT HAS TO BE THE
SAME SIZE AND FONT RIGHT BUT IS
IT IS IT. IS THAT. IS THERE A
WORRYING CONTAINING OR CONTAIN
REQUIRED TO BE AND THE
DISCLOSURE OR CAN THEY JUST PUT
THE PERCENT. OF CALIFORNIA
OLIVE OIL YEAH AND THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT THEY HAVE A WE PUT
IN THE THEY SHALL USE THEY
SHALL BE DECLARED BY THE WORDS
IN LINE TWENTY SIX. IT SAYS THE
PERCENTAGE SHALL BE DECLARED BY
THE WORDS AND WE WERE
PRESCRIPTIVE AND PUTTING THAT
IN FOR WHAT IS THE WORD OR LINE
TWENTY SEVEN MAKE THAT. IDEA
SAID OR THEY SPELL OUT PERCENT
OR YOU CAN USE THE PERCENTAGE
SIGN. EITHER OR- SO IT'S EITHER
OR- HERE YOU CAN EITHER SAVE.
10% WITH THE PERCENTAGE SIGN
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL OR YOU CAN
SPELL OUT PERCENT C. TEN. E. R.
C. NT CALIFORNIA. OKAY AM I AND
WHAT WHAT IS THE WORD
CONTAINING WHAT'S THE VALUE
WHAT LIES THAT IN THERE IF
YOU'RE PUTTING THE PERCENTAGE
CALIFORNIA ALL OR WHAT IS THE
WORD CONTAINED. DEAN JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION. PURPOSES AND
THAT'S HOW WE RUN IT OUT. I
THINKING OF. HIS WHAT I SAID TO
THEM WE WANT TO SURE SAID IT
CAN TAKE. 20% ALL THE WHILE
YEAH SO I APPRECIATE FROM THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THIS
BILL THAT AFTERWARDS. THEY
SHOULD MATTER. AND SO I GUESS
I'M HAVING TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING AND I GUESS I GO
TO THE CHAIR. CHEROKEE MAYBE
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR OWN POINT OF
VIEW ON THIS SURPRISE THE WORD
CONTAIN MATTER CAN BE WORKED.
WITH OF BEING PRESCRIPTIVE HERE.
IT IS A LABEL IT'S A SMALL
OFFICE SPACE SO WHY DOES
CONTAIN MATTER. I THINK-
BECAUSE THIS WAS A LAST MINUTE-
REVELATION WHEN IT WENT THROUGH
THE VILLAGE COUNCIL PROCESS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
PARTIES. ARE IN AGREEMENT ON
ISRAEL BEYOND IF AND ASSEMBLY.
WOMAN IN MISTER BROWN- THAT
WHEN THIS MOVES TO THE NEXT
PHASE THAT THERE WILL BE-
RESOLUTION TO THIS VERY VERY
SMALL ISSUE ON PERCENT.
CALIFORNIA IS THAT CAN YOU
CONFIRM THAT. WE GET MY VERY
FIRST PROPOSAL THAT I HAD COME
THROUGH HERE WAS MUCH LESS
WORDY AND THE PROPOSAL OUT
SPECIFIED. MATHIS THE CITY. OF
FOR DISCLOSURE FOR THE
CONSUMERS NOW SO THERE IS. IT'S
FORTY AND- ELEMENT THAT'S WHAT
THEY WANTED AND SO THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE IT IN THERE BUT WE JUST
TALK ABOUT THE WORD CONTAINS
CORRECT. YEAH WHICH DOESN'T
NEED TO BE THERE. NECESSARILY
YEAH. OKAY BY. ALL OF OUR WITH
THE AS WELL. SO PER DAY YOU CAN.
IN ALL THESE YEARS ARE EXAMPLES
OF TO CHECK FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
SAY. A GLOBAL THIS IS WHAT IT
SAYS. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A VERY
WELL PUT OUT AS WELL. AS A
GLOBAL AND OF ALL OF OILS FROM.
ARJUN CHILE. PORTUGAL IN
CALIFORNIA. WOULD BE CHANGED TO
SAY A GLOBAL ONE OF CALL OF ALL
OF OILS FROM ARGENTINA. CHILE
PORTUGAL. AND TEN FOUR VIEWS IN
HER EXAMPLE 14% OR 25%
CALIFORNIA. REITERATING NOT
ONLY CHANGE BUT THE TERM ALL OF
OIL AGAIN AND THAT LARGE PRINT.
IN THAT EXACT PART. BOB IS HIS
PRESCRIPTIONS AND UNNECESSARY
AGAIN THAT'S WHERE MUCH OF THE
OLIVE OIL. BOB WILL BE ON THE
ON THE PACKAGE AND IT'S FRANKLY
LARGE JUST AT THAT DISCLOSURE.
THERE'S NO REASON TO CONTAIN
THOSE TERMS AT THAT SIZE IN
THAT AREA AND SO WE JUST. GOT
AS IF YOU TAKE OUT THE SECOND
IT STILL REQUIRES US TO DO
PERCENT CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WOULD GO ON WOULD
PROBABLY BE SOMETHING LIKE I
MEAN. FULL DISCLOSURE GLOBAL
BLEND OF. ALL OF THE OILS FROM.
UNIVERSITY PORCH. CHILE AND
1015% CALIFORNIA'S ORDER OF
TWENTY FIVE ZERO WE ARE WE ARE
WE ARE WE CLEAR. MISTER BROWN
AS WELL AS ALSO WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THAT IT WILL
HAVE. EIGHTEEN NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT A NUMBER. WITH EITHER THE
WORD PERCENT FOR THE SYMBOL
PERCENT CALIFORNIA. IF YOU
WOULD JUST IT FOR MY CLARITY
MISTER CHAIR ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT JUST STRIKING THE WORD
CONTAINS IS THAT ALL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- WE TALKED ABOUT
MORE CHANGES. I'M I'M I'M THIS
WAS A LAD THIS WAS A LAST
MINUTE- AND- DEVELOPMENT ON THE
WORD CONTAINED THE THREATENS TO
SHUT. THE PRESCRIBED WE'RE
REQUESTING. IS THE MOMENT
SENATE BILL WELL I WOULDN'T I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THROUGH THE
CHAIR IF WERE A WITNESS IS
GOING TO BE SPEAKING THEY
SHOULD BE DOING IT ON THE MIKE.
I AGREE OKAY OKAY SORRY THANK
YOU SEVENTH. WELL THAT'S IT. IF
YOU REMOVE THAT SENSE THAT'S
ONE OPTION. THROUGH THAT SENDS.
IT WILL STILL SAY THAT AS WE
PERCENT CALIFORNIA'S SIZE THAT
IS NO LESS THAN THE LARGEST
FONT USED TO PRINT CALIFORNIA
ON THE SAME PANEL. SO WE WOULD
REQUEST REMOVING SENSE WHAT
THAT WOULD REMOVE IS BOTH THE
CONTAINS. AN IN THE STATEMENT
ALL OF OIL THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED IN THE SAME FOUGHT IN
SAME SIDE. AS IN THAT
DISCLOSURE. WHAT WHAT WOODS
THEN IT WOULD SAY PERCENT
CALIFORNIA. JUST LIKE IT SAYS
CHILE ARGENTINA OR OR WHATEVER.
AND THOUGH THERE THE TO THE ALL
OF OIL AS WELL BEING IN THE
SAME LARGE FONT. MAYBE IT'S
PROBABLY BIGGER ON THE LABEL IN
ANOTHER SPOT. BUT THIS IS
SPECIFIC TO THIS DISCLOSURE WE
DON'T THINK CALL OF OIL OR
CONTAINS. SHOULD BE PRESCRIBED
IN STATUTE. RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT
BYE MA'AM YES SIR BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THE ISSUE WAS ONLY THAT
CONTAIN RIGHT NOW- MISS ROBBIE
ANI'S ADDED A SECOND ISSUE
HERE. ON THE ISSUE OF CONTAINS
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM- THAT
THE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S AN EXTRA
WORD TO ME- I NEED ALL OF THE
OIL I GUESS I WOULD HAVE TO BE
CLEAR THAT- AGAIN I THINK WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT BEING
SO PRESCRIPTIVE. AND IF IT SAYS
ALL OF WELL IN TERMS OF THE
SETTINGS IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S
REASONABLE TO ME BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF WE WANT TO YOU KNOW
MAYBE THAT'S FOLLOW UP TO THE
CHAIR AND THEN. THE AND THE
SPONSORED THE BILL CAN CAN WORK
ON- AFTER THIS BUT ON THE WORD
CONTAINS I'D BE COMFORTABLE
ELIMINATING THAT PARTICULAR
WORD IF THERE'S AGREEMENT.
UNITED AND I WOULD BE FINE-
WITH THAT WHEN WOULD THERE WAS
AN UNDERSTANDING- ON THE
PARAMETERS OF THIS- I THINK IT
WAS A LAST MINUTE DEVELOPMENT
WITH LUNCH COUNCIL LANGUAGE BUT
I WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT- WE
HAVE WE HAVE MOVED. SO MANY
MOUNTAINS ON- ON THIS
PARTICULAR. ISSUE- MISTER BROWN
AND ASSEMBLY SUFFER. I WOULD
LIKE TO. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
OBJECTION DO YOU HAVE A STRONG
OBJECTION TO THAT MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. WE
HAVE NO OBJECTION TO- REMOVING
THE WORD- CONTAINING- IF
APPROVED BY THE AUTHOR. WHAT I
LIKE T REMIND THE COMMITTEE
OF. THE REASON WE'RE HERE
TODAY. IS A LACK OF SPECIFICITY
IN EXISTING LAW THAT CREATED A
LOOPHOLE FOR THE USE OF THE
TERM CALIFORNIA INCONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE BELIEVE IS BEEN
THE INTENT OF STATE LAW SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. AND SO. I
THINK NOW WE'VE LEARNED IT'S
BETTER TO ERR ON THE SIDE OF
GREATER SPECIFICITY. OF WHAT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE IN THIS
BOTTLE AND WITH THAT WE WOULD
PREFER THAT IT CONTINUES TO SAY
PERCENT. CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL
WHEN IT'S A BLENDED BOTTLE OF
OLIVE OIL THE WORD CONTAINING.
CAN BE SEEN AS EXTRA AND
UNNECESSARY AND IF THE AUTHOR
AGREES WITH IT WE HAVE NO
OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY
ONE. LET'S JUST MAKE IT CLEAR
THE POINT IS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA BRANCH SHOULD BE
CLUB DISCLOSED ON HOW
CALIFORNIA IS ON FOR THE FOR
THE CONSUMER TO LOOK AT SO I
HAVE TO AGREE I MEAN I AGREE
WITH- MISTER BROWN ON- YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT GOING TO I'M NOT GONNA
DI<c.cyan> OF SORBET REALLY THINK.</c>
WE NEED TO BE REALLY CLEAR ON
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS AND
WE TRY TO BE CLEAR PRIOR TO
THIS AMENDMENT AND I'D LIKE TO
JUST SAY NOT NOT EVERYTHING HAS
BEEN THE FROM OF THAT LABEL BUT
IT JUST HAS TO BE VERY CLEAR
THIS CALIFORNIA BRAND MUST
SHOULD BE DISCLOSED. ON HOW
CALIFORNIA IS FOR THE CONSUMERS
FOR CONSUMER. CHOICE SO THEY
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING ON. OKAY BRING IT BRING
IT BACK. SIR HAVE A YEAR YEAH
IT'S ALWAYS DANGEROUS TO WALK
INTO A FOOD FIGHT WITH ADS- YOU
KNOW WHEN IT'S WHEN IT'S BEEN
GOING ON LET ME JUST SAY THAT-
HUH YOU KNOW THE CHALLENGE
WITH. WITH- EIGHT WHEN
EVERYBODY IS SAID THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FOR. IF YOU KNOW
YOUR ABILITY TO EXPLAIN THIS-
AND WHERE YOU WANT TO GO THAT.
ANY TIME THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT
AND YOU END UP IN FRONT OF
SOMEBODY THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
TO MAKE A DECISION AND IT'S
USUALLY A JUDGE- THE STATUTORY
CONSTRUCTION IS THAT WE MEAN
EXACTLY WHAT THE WORDS MEAN AND
THAT IF WE ADDED EXTRA WORDS WE
MEANT THOSE EXTRA WORDS TO MEAN
SOMETHING SO. I ALWAYS ERR ON
IT ON THE SIDE OF LET'S MAKE IT
SIMPLE. AND AND CLEAR AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BECAUSE THE MORE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE BUYING
WHAT'S IN THE BOTTLE. THE
BETTER IT IS- AND- SO I FRANKLY
DON'T SEE THE NEED FOR THE
ENTIRE SENTENCE BUT I AM
PREPARED TO- TO- TO SUPPORT
EITHER THAT OR OR THAT CONTINUE
GETTING RID OF THE WORDS
CONTAINING SO- I DON'T KNOW FOR
MOTIONS BEEN MADE BUT- BUT IF
IT HAS. IF IT HAS NOT- I'M
PREPARED TO MAKE A MOTION THAT
WE JUST TAKE THE SENT TO SEND
US OR WE ADVISE IT THAT'S WHAT
WE THINK SHOULD BE DONE IT GOES
TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE NOT
CONNECTS COMMISSION OFF. OFF
ALWAYS DECIDE WHETHER THEY LIKE
IT IN THERE OR NOT I MEAN IT.
IT'S NOT. I THINK THAT THERE'S
ROOM FOR BOTH. BOTH OPTIONS BUT
I THINK THE STATUTORY
CONSTRUCTION IS SUCH THAT WE
SHOULD JUST TAKE THE SENTENCE
OUT. OKAY RECOMMEND I'M OKAY
WITH THAT YEAH AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WEIRD THIS MATTER
EVEN IN ITS LAST MINUTE-
MANIFESTATION WHAT WE WERE
EXPECTING THAT THIS PARTICULAR
SHE WOULD PROBABLY BE RESOLVED-
THROUGH THE NEXT THROUGH THE
NEXT CMMITTEE HAVING GONE
THROUGH SO MANY. CHANGES FROM
THE ORIGINAL DRAFT SO I THINK
YOU CAN KIND OF GET A SENSE
THAT- BASED ON THE COMMENTS
THAT I'VE HEARD THAT TO WORK
CONTAINS. IS SUPERFLUOUS BOND
IN PERCENTAGE CALIFORNIA OLIVE
OIL IS- APPROPRIATE. BUT I
WOULD LEAVE IT TO THE AUTHOR
ODD TO RESOLVE. THIS VERY VERY
SMALL ISSUE COMPARED TO WHERE
WE STARTED FROM. AS IT MOVES
THROUGH ON THE NEXT COMMITTEE
ANY OTHER FOR ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. AND MISSOURI I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT. THE SENTENCE
ABOVE TALKS ABOUT THE MINIMUM
PERCENTAGE WHICH I ALWAYS
THOUGHT WAS A- SAFER PHRASE
MYSELF BECAUSE OF THE GOOD
PROTECTED THE- PRODUCER FROM
ANY KIND OF LITIGATION THAT WAS
AN EXACT. AND SO I WANT TO GO
OUT ON JOIN WITH CENTER
CABALLERO INSANE I THINK THAT
SENSES EXTRA. IT KIND OF ITS
VISIT I THINK TOO PRESCRIPTIVE
I THINK THAT IT DOES REQUIRE
THE MINIMUM PERCENTAGE OF OLIVE
OIL AND THE SIZE AS THE WORD
CALIFORNIA GETS A VERY CLEAR
AND POWERFUL. AND I THINK THAT
SENDS THIS EXTRA AND AGAIN.
DEPENDING ON MY COLLEAGUES AND
HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION WITH
THAT. IT CAN YOU CAN LEAVE US A
FIVE THE SENTENCE SO WE'RE ON
THE SAME ON THE SAME DAY JUST
AT THE END CENTER COPYRIGHT TO
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IN THE
SENSE BEGINS. ONLINE TWENTY
FIVE OF THE WORD DOT. AND THEN
IT CAN. TO LAW TWENTY- THAT
THAT'S A- SEEMS TO BE A
CLARIFICATION OF WHAT'S ABOVE.
AND WHAT'S ABOVE SEEMS TO BE
CLEAR AS TO WHAT'S REQUIRED ON
THE LABEL. I WOULD AGREE THEY
ACTUALLY RIGHT SO- FROM THERE
AND- I WOULD JUST SAY IT TO DO
A BEHOLDEN ON THE FLYBRIDGE OF
THIS ARE GOING TO BE A
RECOMMENDATION BUT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STILL HAS TO HAS TO TALK
WITH THIS SUPPORTERS AND
SPONSORS AND SEE IF THEY'RE
WILLING TO ACCEPT IT BUT WHAT
WHAT YOU AS I INITIALLY
PROPOSING. IS TO TAKE AT LEAST
TAKE OUT THE WORD BAD- NO I AM
FOR THE OR TALK ABOUT CONTAINS
A AND TO EVALUATE THAT RISK
THAT SENSE IF IT REALLY HAS ANY
VALUE OR NOT YEAH I THINK THAT
THAT IS ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE-
SO WITH THAT- IS THERE CLARITY
WITH THE AUTHOR. THE AND THE
OTHER- PARTIES INVOLVED THAT
THAT SENSE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT IF THAT IS ESSENTIAL
BASED ON OUR- EXAMINATION IT'S
NOT NECESSARY- BUT LEAVE IT FOR
YOU TO RESOLVE THAT- AT. THE
NEXT THE NEXT COMMITTEE LEVEL.
ARE WE CLEAR WITHOUT. WELL
LET'S LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
THIS YEAR I'M HERE KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN I BELIEVE AND I WERE.
REALLY GOOD FAITH AND WE DID
THIS AND WE GREEN PERSON TO THE
LANGUAGE OF BEFORE US AND- I'M
NOT PREPARED TO NEGOTIATE AN
AWARDS RIGHT TODAY IN THE
COMMITTEE AFTER AGREEMENT BUT
I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
HAVE. CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS.
BUT- YOU KNOW THIS BILL WAS
REALLY MADE TO MAKE SURE
CONSUMER PROTECTION MAKE SURE
THE CONSUMER REALIZES IN THE
BOTTLE MAKE SURE THAT OUR
FAMILY FARMERS ARE TAKING KERA.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING I FEEL
LIKE- WE OWE TO THEM BUT I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
THE- WORK AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
IN THAT IS FAIR AND JUST AND
JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR- READING
FROM SECTION DEEM ANY CONTAINER
OF ALL OF WILL PRODUCE PROCESS
SOLD OFFERED FOR SALE GIVEN
AWAY OR POSSESSED IN
CALIFORNIA. WHICH CONTAINS ALL
WILL PRODUCE FROM ALL IS GROWN
IN LOCATIONS OTHER THAN
CALIFORNIA IN WHOLE OR IN PART.
INCLUDES QUOTE THE WORD
CALIFORNIA IN ANY FORM ON THE
PRINCIPAL DISPLAY PANEL SHALL
STATE ON THE SAME PANEL THE
MINIMUM PERCENTAGE OF ALL OF
WILL IN THE CONTAINER PRODUCE
FROM ALL IS GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA. IN A FONT SIZE THAT
IS NO LESS THAN THE LARGEST
FONT USED TO PRINT. QUOTE
CALIFORNIA ON THE SAME PANEL. I
THINK THAT GIVES. ABSOLUTE
DISCLOSURE SO I'LL LEAVE IT TO
YOU- AT THE NEXT EVOLUTION OF
THIS BILL TO RESOLVE- THAT
ADDITIONAL SENSE WHETHER IT'S
SUPERFLUOUS- OR NOT- I DO WANT
TO GIVE. A LOT OF CREDIT- TO
THE AUTHOR AND HER AND HER TEAM
UP FOR WORKING WITH- COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND MY OFFICE AS
WELL AS I- THE ADVOCATES THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM EARLIER THERE
WAS A STRONG POSITIONS
EVENTUALLY THERE WAS A- A
COMPROMISE BILL THAT I THINK
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO ALLOW
FOR. CALIFORNIA TO BE BETTER
PROTECTED AS POTENTIAL BRAND
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THAT
CONSUMERS. ARE WELL CAPABLE OF
UNDERSTANDING. A MINIMUM
CONTENT OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF
THE WORLD IN A GIVEN BOTTLE
WHEN THEY'RE PURCHASING THAT
ITEM SO- I KNOW THAT THERE WAS
A- A MOTION- WELL THERE WAS ONE
MADE EARLIER BUT I THINK WE
HAVE SINCE REVISED POLITICAL
MOTIONS. TRANSPORTATION THIS
YEAR I'M VERY RESPECTFUL OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU HAD WITH
THE AUTHOR AND I DON'T WANT TO
GET IN THE WAY OF THAT
AGREEMENT OKAY. BUT THE WORDS
THAT YOU READ WITH THOSE
RESERVE THOSE WITH THE IF THAT
WAS THE AGREEMENT THAT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. YES OKAY- SO NOT
GOING 2% OF THE DIRECTOR SENATE
THEY WERE ARGUING ABOUT WAS
THAT PART OF YOUR AGREEMENT
WITH YASSER. MY RECOLLECTION
WAS THAT THAT WAS CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE FROM LEDGE COUNCIL
REGIONAL CAN YOU CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THAT- THERE WAS AN
AGREEMENT TO SPECIFY THE
PERCENTAGE AMOUNT OF CALIFORNIA
ALL OF US ON THE FRONT OF THE
LABEL. THE WORDING THAT WAS
USED WAS DONE WITH MYSELF AND
WITH LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IT
CONTAINED. THAT WAS NOT AN
AGREED UPON WORD BUT A BIT
THANK PERCENT OLIVE OIL WAS
PART OF THE AGREEMENT SO THE
WORKCONTAINED IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS PUT IN. BY COUNSEL
MYSELF THAT IF IT'S TO WORRY HE
COULD PROBABLY REMOVE IT STILL
HAVE THE SAME- THE SAME. JUST
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER FINAL.
OF FROM THE DAY. OF YEAH I MOVE
THAT WE- WE- SUPPORT. THIS
LANGUAGE- AND TAKE OUT THAT ONE
SENTENCE THAT STARTS ON NINE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE. AND
ENDS ON THE LINE TWENTY EIGHT
AND THAT WE MAKE THAT
RECOMMENDATION TO THE NEXT
MEETING. ALL RIGHT OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS
ARTICULATED- WITH THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. ARKANSAS WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE CENTER BARGES FIVE
BRIDGES HI HER TADO. CABALLERO
CAREER HIGH EGGMAN I THINK WHEN
I GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL- PUT THAT BUILT
ON CALL ASSEMBLY WOMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTERS FOR YOUR
INPUT APPRECIATED. ALL RIGHTS
THE GUYS THAT ARE KIND OF
CAREER SAID IT BEST YOU KNOW
FOOD FIGHT ON THURSDAY
AFTERNOON DOESN'T GET ANY
BETTER THAN THAT ARE ASKED. BUT
THE- ARE MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT
AUTHOR. ARE WE HAVE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VIA FOOD WHY. OR MAKE
CERTAIN THAT I'M SAYING THAT
CORRECTLY. IS THAT GOOD PERFECT
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE
BEFORE US FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THREE FIVE ZERO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS EACH YEAR
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON
CLARIFICATIONS TO LANGUAGE. I
WILL ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS
TODAY AB THREE FIFTY CREATES A
THREE YEAR PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
LANDOWNERS IN CRITICAL
OVERDRAFT FACE AND TO HELP. THE
COMMISSION PLANS EVALUATE THE
POSSIBLE IMPACT ON THEIR
PROPERTIES FROM IMPLEMENTATION
OF SIGMA. AND ACCESS TO THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF
ALTERNATIVE USE OF THEIR LAND.
I UNDERSTAND- I UNDERSTAND
THERE THERE'S BEEN CONCERNS
RAISED ON THE DEFINITION OF
LANDOWNERS TO LIMIT THE
ASSISTANCE TO NON. CORPORATE
INDEPENDENT LANDOWNERS I SHARE
THE CONCERNS AND I AND CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE THAT
ADDED THESE AMENDMENTS TO BE
INCLUSIVE. THOSE WHO ORGANIZED
THE CORPORATION WELL
MAINTAINING INTENTIONS. OF THE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL HAS YET
BEEN ENJOY BY SO. AND HAS
RECEIVED NO. NO VOTE. WITH ME%
TODAY TO TESTIFY AS TO IS BACK.
PATTERSON WITH THE FARM TRUCK.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT- SO YOUR
FIRST WITNESS IS KATIE
PATTERSON REPRESENTING AMERICAN
FARM LAND TRUST AND I BELIEVE
SHE IS ON THE COAST LINE MOTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE SEE IF MISS
PATTERSON IS AVAILABLE. I AM
HERE WONDERFUL. PLEASE PROCEED
GREAT EIGHT THANK YELL AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BE
A GOOD ONE- SO GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN
MY NAME'S KATIE PATTERSON AND
I'M THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
MANAGER FOR AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
THREE FIFTEEN. THE ANTI UNITED
FARMERS IN BY MILITANT
POLICYMAKERS AND DEVELOPING
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS LIKE EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY THAT PROTECT
FARMLAND AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO WHERE ARE WE NOW WELL WATER
SCARCITY A CHANGING CLIMATE NEW
REGULATIONS IN A GROWING
POPULATION ARE JUST SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING FARMERS AND
FARMLAND. IN CALIFORNIA NAFTA'S
WORK IN THE FAMILY CAN VALLEY
IT'S AND WE FOUND THAT HIGH
QUALITY FARMLAND MORE
PRODUCTIVE VERSATILE AND
RESILIENT BUT THE RELIABLE
WATER SOURCE VERY LIMITED. WITH
ONLY 9% OF THE WORK WITH
ROUGHLY SIX MILLION ACRES OF
IRRIGATED FARMLAND IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY BEING OF HIGH
QUALITY AND EXPERIENCING LOW
WATER STRESS. AND ACCORDING TO
THE STATE- DRAFT GROUNDWATER
REPORT STATEWIDE GROUNDWATER
OVERDRAFT IS ESTIMATED TO BE IN
THE RANGE OF TWO MILLION TO TWO
AND A HALF MILLION ACRE FEET
PER YEAR- BY THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
SOME INDICATIONS ARE NEARLY.
THAT NEARLY 40% OF THE CURRENT
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CROPLAND OR
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF LAND MAY NEED TO BE
VALID OR RETIRED TO BRING THE
GROUNDWATER AQUIFERS AND ABOUT.
THE SHIFT WOULD HAVE AN
ECONOMIC COST OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS PER. YEAR THREE PP I
THINK. THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
THERE BE THAT THE COST. WITH
THE GT SUSTAINED GROUNDWATER.
BUT THE LONG TERM AND IMPACT TO
BE. CONSIDERABLY GREATER IF
GROUNDWATER USE IS NOT MANAGE A
FAMOUSLY AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS NOT MADE
AVAILABLE FOR CONSERVATION
PLANNING. ACROSS THE STATE
FARMERS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
DEVELOP NON FARM CONSERVATION
PLANS AND REACHING THE WATER
USE REDUCTION GOAL BUT THE ACT.
WE RECOGNIZE IN MANY CASES
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
MAY REQUIRE INTENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. INCLUDING LANGUAGE
SUPPORT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS AFFECT MY- EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY WOULD ENCOURAGE
INNOVATION AND ALTERNATE
ALTERNATIVE ECONOMICALLY VIABLE
APPROACHES TO AGRICULTURAL LAND
MANAGEMENT. AND SEEKS TO
PREVENT UNNECESSARY FOLLOWING.
INCREASING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND CONSERVATION PLANNING FOR
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS AT THE
CENTRAL TO HELP THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ACHIEVING. THE
STATE OFFICIALS CALLED A
BALANCED AND SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT WHEN
FARMS AND RANCHES ARE
MANAGEABLE MULTIPLE BENEFITS
THEY HELP TO PROTECT THE MOST
VALUABLE. AND PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL LAND PROTECCI
SERVICE GROUND WATER SUPPLIES.
AND SUPPORT CRITICAL HABITAT
FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
PATTERSON ARE MOVING ON TO ME
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT AND
FITNESS ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. ANYONE WISHING TO. ALL
RIGHT. I ANY WITNESSES IN THE
OVER ROOM WE SHOULD TEST FIND
SUPPORT OF A THREE FIVE. ALSO
CLEAR ON THAT- MOVING ON TO
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR- DO WE
HAVE ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
SUPPORT AB THREE FIVE ZERO IN
OF SO IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE
US. AND THE NUMBER IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB IS THREE FIFTY MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE FIFTY. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE FOUR IN Q. MISTER CHAIR
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ORDER ONLINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINES OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS
PAUL YOUR IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE MADERA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE NUMBERS REBEKAH MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT DOOR TO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR TERRORISTS- GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS WORKING TO
CARVE OUT TO ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION WE ARE IN
THE SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. TO
EXPAND IT TO ALL- GROUNDWATER
BASINS IN THE STATE NOT JUST
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT THAT WE
HAVE A REMINDER OF AB THREE
FIFTY WE ARE IN SUPPORT CAN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY
HERE LINE IS OPEN. DAVE RENTON
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS WE SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
THE. ARE YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR JUST ONE
LAST CHECK IF YOU COULD DO ONE
MORE TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FIFTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
IN HERE FROM OPPOSITION- THOUGH
THERE IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS LISTED FREE B. THREE
FIFTY ANY OTHER INDIVIDUAL. IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
PLEASE APPROACH THE LECTERN
SEEING AT NINE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE- ANYONE IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. OPPOSITION THREE
FIFTY ALSO OVERWHELMING
PRESENCE IN ROOMS- IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. ALL RIGHT TO
MOVE ON WITH THIS IS IN THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR ANY OPPOSITION. ON
THE TELECONFERENCE. TO AB THREE
FIFTY. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FIFTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FIFTY.
MAKE SURE WE HAVE ONE IN Q. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. A GOOD AFTERNOON
RESEARCHER MEMBERS TAYLOR OCEAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A POSITION
JUST OF CONCERN- WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE AUTHOR'S INTENT OF
THE SALE AND BEING CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND OUR CONCERN IS
REALLY PREDICATED ON THIS
INCORPORATED FARM DEFINITION-
ADMITTED IN AN ALPHA AND
ARTICULATED BY THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO WE HOPE IT'S
RECTIFIED SHORTLY I THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MATER ANYONE
ELSE ONE LAST FINAL CALL FOR
INDIVIDUAL WITNESS THANK YOU
OPEN UP IF YOU'RE NOT BUSINESS
OF AB THREE FIFTEEN A PRESS AND
THEN. ZERO AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME MISTER ALL RIGHTS ARE
THANK YOU FOR ON OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BRING IT
BACK- TO MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS
OR ENQUIRIES FROM THE BOARD. TO
RECOVER EURO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CAN YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE I'M
I'M MUST'VE MISSED IT- IN TERMS
OF THAT WAS JUST RAISED- I
BELIEVE BY THE FARM BUREAU- IN
REGARDS TO INCORPORATED FIRMS.
IF YOU DON'T MIND SENATOR IF I
CAN HAVE K<c.cyan> PATTERSON-</c>
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. WHICH WAS
OUR OUR OUR WITNESS. HERE IS
MISS PATTERSON MODERATORS MISS
PATTERSON STILL AVAILABLE
ONLINE. I'M HERE. YES TO ENTER
THE THIRD QUESTION IN REGARDS
TO- AND THEN MEANT THAT
OCCURRED IN THE ASSEMBLY- THERE
WAS A PORTION OF LANGUAGE THAT
INCLUDED- RESTRICTING-
APPLICANTS OR RECIPIENTS OF THE
PROGRAM- WHO ARE INCORPORATED-
AND THAT IS SOMETHING WE ARE
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THE TEN
COMMANDMENTS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VEHICLES WHILE HAS FADED AND
HIS INITIAL COMMENTS AND WE'VE
BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH FARM
BUREAU AND OTHER- ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN THAT-
BUT STILL PROGRESSING AND ARE
ARE LOOKING TO ACTIVELY-
MODIFIED LANGUAGE SO IT CAN BE
MORE INCLUSIVE- AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS. BY THE
COMMITTEE. SENATE LET ME LET ME.
IT YEAH WE HAD A TO ADDRESS
WANTED TO CAN BY. BY ADDING
THERE WERE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CLARIFY- AND WORK WITH. THAT SO
AT IT IT'S- I GUESS BY NOW IT'S
THE SECOND HOUSE AND SO IT IT.
IT EITHER EITHER YOU AGREED
THAT INCORPORATED IS GOOD OR
IT'S NOT OR YOU HAVEN'T- I'M
I'M JUST NOT SURE WHERE YOU'RE
GOING YOU'RE GOING WITH IT AND
I AM OKAY WHATEVER IT IS YOU
DECIDE I JUST I JUST NEEDED TO
UNDERSTAND- KIND OF WORD THE
OBJECTION IS COMING FROM- AND I
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE- THERE.
THERE MANY TIMES WHAT HAPPENS
IS PEOPLE SAY WELL THE
CORPORATIONS ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE CREATING. IT THERE'D BIG
CORPORATIONS AND QUITE FRANKLY
WHEN I STARTED MY OWN LAW
PRACTICE WE WERE PARTNERSHIP
SETTLED A BIG CASE AND WE
BECAME A CORPORATION BECAUSE
YOU HAVE MORE PROTECTIONS. AND
THERE ARE MORE OPTIONS FOR YOU
IN TERMS OF- FINANCES AND WE
WERE STILL THE SAME FOR PEOPLE
THAT WE WERE WHEN WE WERE A
PARTNERSHIP SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET A SENSE OF. YOU KNOW
WHAT OF THE SIZE OF THE FARM
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HELPING.
AND IF INCORPORATION BECOMES
THE BY THE BARRIER IT WILL AT
WHAT LEVEL DOES IT BECOME A
BARRIER AND- AND SO I'M I'M
JUST LOOKING FOR SOME WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO GO WITH THIS I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL. I
WANT TO SUPPORT IT I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF WHERE
YOU SEE IT GOING SO THAT I CAN
TELL YOU MINNESOTA STARTED
TODAY BUT UNLESS IT GETS FIXED
BY THE TIME IT GETS TO THE
FLOOR. I AND YOU HAVE A RANGE
OF FOR WHO YOU'RE TRYING TO
HELP WITH THIS- ARE YOU MAY NOT
SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR. YES
THAT'S RIGHT. THAT'S A
REASONABLE QUESTION. YES I
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR. WE IT
WOULD ALLOW. MAN TO THE
LANGUAGE AND- WE UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE COMMITTEE- IN THE
OTHER HOUSE- WAS LOOKING TO-
CREATES- PRIORITIZATION
POSSIBLY FOR MEDIUM OUR SMALL.
ARMS AND- WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE
WERE ALREADY LOOKING AT THE
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED- YOU
KNOW FARMERS AND RANCHERS DOWN
TO THE LAND AND- YOU KNOW WE
ARE. COMMITTED TO. TO FINDING
WAYS TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE IN
THAT- AND WE'VE BEEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF.
AGRICULTURE TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T BECOME A- LIMITATION-
FOR THEM IN THE LANGUAGE AND-
YOU KNOW. WE STILL HAVE TO MORE
WORK TO DO THERE- YOU KNOW IT
WOULD BE OUR PREFERENCE AT THAT
LANGUAGE- WHAT'S NOT THERE- IN
ORDER IN ORDER TO ALLOW MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY- AT THAT. POINT IN
TIME BASED ON WHERE WE ARE WITH
THE NEGOTIATIONS IN
CONVERSATION- I WISH I COULD
OFFER YOU A LOT MORE ADDITIONAL
INSURANCES. BUT YOU KNOW THAT
THE PROFIT BUT STILL NEEDS TO
PLAY OUT AND I. APPRECIATE THE
POSITION YOU'RE IN- IN.
POSSIBLY OFFERING CANADA
SUPPORT. UNTIL THEY- REACH THE
FOURTEENTH ABOUT WHAT CAN BE
DONE WELL THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I WILL
SUPPORT IT TODAY AND- AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL- GET SOME OF
THAT. WORKED OUT BY THE TIME IT
IT HIT SUPPORT. BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR AT YOUR
EXPLANATION MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME. THANK YOU THANKS.
A LOT. OF OUR CAMP. JUST A
POINT CLARIFICATION I THINK
BEGINNING OF YOUR OF YOUR
COMMENTS- YOU'D INDICATED THAT
YOU WERE ACCEPTING. SOME SIX
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. CAN YOU
REALLY- REAFFIRMED YEAH. WHAT
YOU SAID EARLIER SO ALLOW THE
CDF TO SIGN. THAN ONE TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS- ASSISTANT PROVIDER. TO
EACH OVERDRAFT BASIN. AS
NEEDED. CLARIFIED THAT IT IS. A
DISTINCT AND SEPARATE PROGRAM.
FROM HEALTHY SOIL PROGRAM.
STRIKE THE WORD REGULATIONS
EVERY. WITH RICH. TO ALLOW. TO
THE CD F. PROCEDURES. THANK YOU
AND THE CONSULTANT- THE ARE CAN.
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION THAT WE
HAD DISCUSSED AND GUESTS PLEASE
YEAH THANK YOU- THE- THING KNOW
WHETHER A COMMENTS AND- OUR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK EACH YEAR
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NIGHT OUT THANK YOU ARE WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR A BI CENTER
GLAZER OF AB THREE FIVE ZERO-
IT WOULD BE TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST- AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS THAT CORRECT.
IF ALL RIGHT KENTUCKY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE FIVE
ZERO GORGEOUS AL RIGHT BORDERS
HI HER TADO. CABALLERO CAREER
HIGH EGGMAN. GLAZER GLAZER AYE
GLORIA WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT-
STILL ON CALL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE- THIS ASSEMBLY
AG COMMITTEE BILL AB SEVEN ONE
NINE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. THE FLOOR IS YOURS WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS GREAT SEE EVERYBODY'S
AFTERNOON AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL HERE TODAY- WHICH IS- THE
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE OMNIBUS
BILL FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
SO IT'S A LET'S JUST IT'S A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
SUPPOSED TO MAKE- CHANGES IN
FOUR AREAS FIRST IS A TECHNICAL
CHANGE OR CLEAN UP REGARDING.
OPPORTUNITY PURCHASING- AND
ONCE AGAIN ALLOWING THE
CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION THE STATE
FERRIER CAL EXPO TO REGAIN THE
USE OF OPPORTUNITY PURCHASING.
WELL RUN BILL.THERE WAS A
SERVICE IS SEVEN ONE NINE
CORRECT SEVEN OH I'M SORRY ON
THE- ON THE SCHEDULE IT WAS THE
FIRST WHEN I STARTED OUT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT IT DOES NOT WE'LL
START TO AGAIN JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION AB SIXTY THREE
WAS THAT ON CONSENT ON CONSOLE.
ALL RIGHT OUTSTANDING AB SO
ONE. SEVEN ONE NINE AGAIN AGAIN
FREESHEET THE OPPORTUNITY THIS
TODAY- BUT SEVEN ONE NINE- IS-
AN ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE-
COMMITTEE BILL THAT MAKES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE APIARY PROTECTION ACT- THAT
INCLUDE CHANGING THE MAKEUP OF
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNER FOOD AND
CULTURES- CDFA- APIARY-
ADVISORY BOARD REVISING SOME
DEFINITIONS AND UPDATING US
PROVISIONS TO REFLECT CURRENT-
THE TECHNOLOGY IN INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICES. YOU KNOW MANY OF THE
PROPOSED CHANGES IN THIS BILL
WERE REQUESTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION- AND WHO WORKED-
OR- CONSULTED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURE THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL- THE
COMMISSIONERS AND SOLICITATION
AND OTHER INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS AND SO AND AS
WE'VE DONE THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS YOU KNOW
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON ON
THIS BILL- AND YOU KNOW- TO-
YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING CONCERNS AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. YOUR STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
WORKED OUT- CHANGES TO THIS
CURRENT BILL- THAT WE ARE- THAT
WE WILL BE TAKING IN THE NEXT-
THE- NEXT- THE COMMITTEE YEAH
PLAN AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
ADDRESSING CONCERNS ABOUT
TIMELY NOTIFICATION OF BEHIND
INSPECTION INSPECTOR TRAINING
BROADENING THE DEFINITION OF
BROKERS TO ENSURE EXPANDED
COMPLIANCE AND- CLARIFYING THE
DISPOSAL OF INFECTED HIVES-
IT'S A WITH ME- TO- PROVIDES OF
TESTING. BY PHONE IS. SO SEN-
THE NEW- REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE. BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION- AND SO AND SHE'S
ALSO HERE TO ANSWER ANY- THE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU-
SO SIMPLY REVERSES WITNESS- IS-
SO SON- I DID NOT REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA BEEKEEPERS I BELIEVE
SHE IS- ON THE CO HOST LINE
MODERATE CAN YOU CONFIRM. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON THE JURY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SAYS THE MATTER
LAST- WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE KAY BEHALF OF THAT
CALIBER STATE. A THIRTY PROUD
SPONSOR AT EIGHTY SEVEN ONE
NINE. I'M MANY OF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGE
BEEKEEPING INDUSTRY IN THE
COUNTRY ON THE THREE QUARTER OF
ANY DOCUMENTED COMMERCIAL SB
PROCLAMATION IS CONDUCTED
CALIFORNIA AND CLOSE TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND COLONIES OF
BEES ARE OPERATED BY FOUR
HUNDRED COMMERCIAL INFORMIX
MARSHALL. P. KEEPERS. I'M HERE
HELPING PEOPLE CRITICAL TO OUR-
INDUSTRY WHICH WHY WE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY. WITH THAT CAL.
AGRICOLE COME AND FEEL FEELER
ASSOCIATION. AND FORMER
MEASURED. HELLO THE BETTER
INDUSTRY PRACICE IS AMEND OUT
LANGUAGE AND PROVIDE
CONSTITUENCIES THE CODE. WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING COMMERCE
WITH. AS THE S. AND MEMBER-
THOSE CONVERSATION ARE ON AND
WE WILL BE WORKING ON AND THEN
BOB WE'VE ALL AGREED TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE- WILL CONTINUE
WORK WITH ON OF THE BILL
FORWARD- THANK YOU OFFER AND IF
YOU STAFF AFTER ON THAT'S NOT.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY WE RESPECT ON THE I. A
NINE- I HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAPPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE MOVING ON ANY WITNESSES
INSTEAD HERE AND THREE ONE NINE
ONE- APPROACH SELECT. SEEING
NONE- TO THE- ROOM OF THE
WISHES AB. ONE NINE- SEE NONE
ARE MOVING AWAY- BE TELE.
MODERATOR WE HAVE ANY FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE NINE.
PLEASE KEEP HIM UP AND LET US
KNOW HOW MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE. THANK YOU HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO APPEAR IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN ONE NINE.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE JUST HAVE
ONE IN Q. AND WE WILL GO TO.
THAT LINE IN ONE MOMENT HERE.
THANK YOU AGAIN WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN ONE NINE.
AND THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
TO QUEUE UP THAT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS TIM CALLAHAN-
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER WAS
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
REPRESENTING. THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS AND
SEALERS ASSOCIATION. AND WE
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MODER ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
ONE NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER A SUPPORT YOU AT
THIS TIME HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
ALL OF US SUPPORTERS BECAUSE
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
TO MODERNIZATION. THOUGH I DO
NOT BELIEVE THERE IS A LEAD
WITNESS LISTED IN OPPOSITION
FOR A. B. SEVEN ONE NINE.
MOVING ON- ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SEEKING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION. MOVING
ON TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM. ALSO
SEEING NO ONE THERE- MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE ON TO TELECONFERENCE
ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SEVEN ONE
NINE PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP AND
LET US KNOW HOW MANY MIGHT BE
IN THE QUEUE IF SO. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN ONE NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. SEVEN ONE NINE. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE ONE IN Q. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINES OPEN. THANK YOU I'M
WONDERING IF YOU'RE EVER GONNA
DO THE LOADING VELVA LIVESTOCK
ONE. THE MOBILE SLAUGHTERHOUSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH STILL
HANGING ON WATER. THIS THANK
YOU MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION-
TO THIS BILL. YEAH ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN ONE NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ARE
BRINGING DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS MEMBERS CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU CHAIR I
THINK IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
MISTER REAVIS- AS AS YOU KNOW A
BEEKEEPER'S DAUGHTER THIS IS
THAT OUR LIFETIME AND I'M I'M
VERY PROUD TO BE. SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY I WOULD MAKE THE
MOTION IN A THIN AND I THINK
IT. WOULD PROBABLY NEED MORE. A
COUPLE AWARENESS CAMPAIGN TO I
DON'T KNOW PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
BEEKEEPING COMMUNITY ITS
COMMERCIAL BEEKEEPERS IN- AND
AGRICULTURE. IN THIS GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I AM
GLAD TO SEE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE AND HOW WE- LOOK AT
BEEKEEPERS AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT WITHOUT
WITHOUT BEES CALIFORNIA WOULD
NOT BE. AND IN THE AMOUNT THAT
COME IN FROM OUT OF STATE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. SO THIS JUST GIVES
EXTRA TOOLS SO I WOULD MOVE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU WISH TO CLOSE
BUT JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
MR ALL RIGHT- TWO EIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM CENTER EGMAN ON
EIGHTY SEVEN ONE NINE-
CONSULTATIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SURE. AB SEVEN ONE NINE DO
PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FORGES ALL RIGHT YOUR BRIDGES
HI HER TADO. CABALLERO RIGHT
NOW WE ARE AYE. EGGMAN AYE
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE IS IT HI
ALL RIGHT WE WILL PUT THIS BILL
ON A CALL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BYE BYE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT
AUTHOR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AB ONE ZERO ZERO NINE
IN AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO FILE
ITEMS EIGHT AND NINE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PRESENT AB ONE THOUSAND
NINE THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND STAFF MEMBERS
OR IS IT AFTERNOON THAT. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TEN OH
NINE WHICH ESTABLISHES THE FARM
TO SCHOOL FOOD OF PROGRAM- THIS
WILL BE WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
FARM TO FORK IN THE DEPARTMENT%
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AND
PROPOSES FUNDING FOR A REGIONAL
PILOT PROGRAM. TO ESTABLISH
THREE FARM TO SCHOOL FOOD HUBS
IN NORTHERN CENTRAL AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. FOOD HUBS
OFFER A REGIONAL ALLIES
APPROACH TO FOOD DISTRIBUTION
THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL A SUCCESSFUL MODEL
FOR PROMOTING DIRECT FARM AND
RANCH SALES TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS RESULTED
AND UNPREDICTABILITY AND LOSS
OF MARKETS. AND THAT'S HAVE A
DISPOPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL SCALE
FARMERS PARTICULARLY
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
FARMERS OF COLOR- JUST IN
REFORM INCREASINGLY CALLS FOR
MORE REGIONAL ALLIES FOOD
SYSTEMS WHICH IN TURN PROVIDE
GREATER RESILIENCE IN TERMS OF
NATURAL OR PUBLIC. HEALTH
DISASTER IN TIMES OF NATURAL
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER.
DURING THE PANDEMIC THOSE AREAS
THAT HAD COMMUNITY FACING FOOD
HUBS WERE ABLE TO PIVOT QUICKLY
TOWARDS RE DIRECTING THEIR
SUPPLY CHAINS TO AREAS OF NEED.
AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF THE
SUCCESS OF THIS MODEL IS. AN
ENTITY CALLED THE COMMON MARKET
WHICH IS A NON IS A NON PROFIT
FOOD HAVE OPERATING IN
PHILADELPHIA NEW YORK GEORGIA
AND TEXAS. AND WHICH PROVIDED
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL FARMERS AND
EMERGENCY FOOD RELIEF DURING
THE PANDEMIC. MARKELLE LEADS
THE NATION IN AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION WITH THE FARM
ECONOMY VALUED AT FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS. WE LAG BEHIND IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF REGIONAL ALLIES
FOOD SYSTEMS WHICH REQUIRE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN
AGGREGATION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND DINNER
THAT'S NEEDED TO INCREASE
PURCHASING OF LOCAL CLIMATE
FRIENDLY AND EQUITABLY PRODUCED
FOOD. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT- HI IS A PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT INTERMEDIARY SUPPLY
CHAIN SUPPORT FOR SCHOOLS AND
OTHER LARGE SCALE INSTITUTIONS.
AB TEL NINE WILL INCREASE
PURCHASING OF LOCAL CLIMATE
FRIENDLY AND EQUITABLY PRODUCED
FOOD BUILD A BETTER FOOD SYSTEM
ECONOMY SUPPORT LOCAL FARMING
ECONOMIES ACCELERATE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE. AN
EMPLOYEE FOOD SYSTEM WORKERS
ADDITIONALLY THESE FOOD HUBS
WILL SERVE AS A MODEL FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE TO FOLLOW AND
HOPEFULLY ADOPT. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY HAS NO NO VOTES
AND NO OPPOSITION AND I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE PAULA DANIELS
CO FOUNDER OF THE CENTER FOR
GOOD FOOD PURCHASING AND SCOTT
BURNT AND URBAN FARMER AND THE
COORDINATOR OF THE RIVERSIDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FOOD
UP. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TOWN I. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- MODERATOR CAN YOU-
QUEUE UP- BOTH PAULA DANCER
WITH PAULA DANIELS AND THEN
SCOTT BURKE. ALL ON THE LINE.
AND PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO TWO MINUTES RESPECTIVELY
TOTAL FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
BORDERS CONFIRMING THAT YOU CAN
HEAR ME THIS HOLIDAY AND YES
MA'AM. OKAY BORGES THANK YOU
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M CO FOUNDER OF THE CENTER
FOR GOOD FOOD PURCHASING WE-
ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED THE GOOD
FOOD PURCHASING PROGRAM WITHIN
THE LOS ANGELES GOOD POLICY
COUNCIL WHICH I FOUNDED TEN
YEARS AGO. AS AN INITIATIVE
THAT MAYOR VARICOSE OUT WHEN I
WAS A SENIOR ADVISER. LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS
AMONG THE FIRST TO ADOPT OUR
PROGRAM IN TWENTY TWELVE AND AS
A RESULT IN ONE YEAR THEY WENT
FROM LESS THAN 10% LOCAL
SOURCING OUR PRODUCE. TO NEARLY
60% PUMPING ABOUT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE LOCAL
FOOD ECONOMY AND CREATING OVER
A HUNDRED FIFTY NEW LOCAL JOBS.
ARE PROGRAM EXPANDED NATIONALLY
AND IT'S NOW HOUSED IN THE
CENTER WE WORK WITH FIFTY SEVEN
INSTITUTIONS IN TWENTY THREE
CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
EVERYWHERE FROM BY PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK AND CHICAGO TO HAWAII
AND IN CALIFORNIA ALONE WERE IN
TWENTY TWO PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
FOURTEEN OF WHICH ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HE TWENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION AND A
COMBINED ONE HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS ON FOOD. PER
YEAR THEY'RE NOW DIRECTING AN
AVERAGE OF 16% OF THAT TO THEIR
LOCAL FOOD ECONOMIES SUPPORTING
HUNDRED THE CALIFORNIA
LIVELIHOOD. BUT THEY'D LIKE TO
AND CAN DO SO MUCH MORE.
ESPECIALLY TO SUPPORT THE
SMALLER FARMERS BETTER 80%
CALIFORNIA'S FARMING POPULATION
BUT TO DO THAT THEY DO NEED
WHAT AB TEN OH NINE MAKES
POSSIBLE. BASED ON OUR RESEARCH
AND WORKING WITH THESE
INSTITUTIONS OVER THE PAST
DECADE IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
FUNCTIONS COULD HELP SERVE IN
CREATING A MORE DIRECT LINK IN
THE LOCAL SUPPLY CHAIN. ARE
THAT CRUCIAL MISSING PIECES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN MENTIONED
AND HELPING LOCAL FARMERS REACH
THE MARKET. A LARGE
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF FOOD HAD
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AS YOU
MENTIONED MOSTLY IN THE
NORTHEAST MIDWEST AND THE GREAT
LAKES AEAS. AND ABOUT A THIRD
OF THEM HAVE RECEIVED FEDERAL
STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FUNDING. THE STATE'S HE COULD
HAVE DONE OTHER LOCAL
PROTECTION INFRASTRUCTURE IS
CRITICAL TO SERVING THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN HEALTHY FOOD ALONG
WITH THE GOALS OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB CREATION.
CALIFORNIA CAN FULFILL ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN AGRICULTURE
AGAIN WITH AB. TEN OH NINE
WHICH HAS A CLEAR PURPOSE AND
CONNECT HOW. SMALLER SOCIALLY
THE- HIERO AND CLIMATE SMART.
TO THE SIGNATURE MARKET
OPPORTUNITY OF LARGE IS TO LIKE
DISTRICT. THIS IS KEY TO ATTACK.
POST PENDANT SECOND RECOVERY
FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS. SURE
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE FOR ANY
FUTURE CRISIS. SUPPORTS CLIMATE
SMART AND PARALYMPIC PRODUCTION
PRACTICES AND FURTHERS THE WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
BY INCREASING ACCESS TO OUR
LOCALLY GROWN HEALTHY FOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MOVING ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS. HELLO MY NAME IS
FAT BURN NEAR ME YES SIR. HI MY
NAME IS SCOTT BURNS I'M NOT TO
THE COORDINATOR FOR RIVERSIDE
WITHOUT ENTERTAINER BUT PARKER
THE RIVERSIDE PUT OTHERS JUST
HIDEOUS FATE AND USDA GRANT
FUNDED ENTITY OF THE RIVERSIDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
NUTRITION SERVICES DEPARTMENT.
THE REPRESENTATIVE WAS A PILOT
PROJECT THE TERM IN THE
VISIBILITY OF OPERATING A FOOD
HUB WELL UTILIZED EXISTING.
SCHOOL INFRASTRUCTURE. SUGARMAN
PART OF THE AIMED AT YOUR PRO
FIRST FROM SMALL FARMER.
PROVIDED NEEDED SUPPORT LOCAL
ECONOMIES- UP IS NOT ONLY GROW
FUND BUT RECEIVED BENEFITS IN
KIND TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
INCLUDING TRUCK WAREHOUSE
IMPRESSED. AND I COUNTY AND
THEN SUPPORT WITHOUT WITH
GRANTED IN KIND THE COOPER NOT
BE VIABLE. UNLIKE MY COMMERCIAL
JUST BE GOOD OF THE DROUGHT
MICRO MARGIN TRADITIONAL
DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS ONLY. A
LOT PERCENT. OF EVERY TOPSAIL
BOG AT FARMERS. WELCOME WILL
RETURN TO NINETY PER. OF EACH
SALE FAR. IMPORTANTLY COULD
HELP CERTAINLY POKER NUMBER
ENOUGH LOCAL FARM. HAVE
INTEREST TO PASS WAS FOR FAILED.
BUT SMALL FARMERS NOT HAVE THE
TIME OR WITH THE CREATE. FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE CALL NINETY
PANDEMIC THE RECENT BOOK WAS
ABLE TO QUICKLY PIVOT AND
DISTRICT ALMOST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER UNIT COULD. THE OF
THE DEGREE LAYS. MALL MEDIUM
CROP FARMERS ARE INDEPENDENT
PROPER NOT LOOKING HAND
YOURSELF. THEY JUST WANTED THIS
TO BE SYSTEM THAT WORKS THEIR
FAVOR AND PUT UP SOME.
EQUITABLE EQUITABLE THE-
PROGRAM. THANK YOU AND I KNOW
YOU'RE JUST OF. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTS ARE MOVING ON TO THE
WITH IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY. SEEING NONE
MOVING INTO OVERFLOW ROOM
SUPPORT OF AB. TEN THOUSAND
NINE. SEEING NONE MOVING ON TO
TELECONFERENCE MATER DO WE HAVE
ANY FOLKS WISHING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI- TEN OH NINE
N. PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW MANY
FOLKS MIGHT BE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB TEN OH NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN OH NINE. AND WE HAVE
FOUR IN Q. MISTER CHAIR ARE
LET'S START HIM UP. THANK YOU
OF OUR LINE OF EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERMARKETS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO VOTE TO
LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BRONSTON COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER IT'S STILL.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
PEOPLE ABANDONED OUR CALIFORNIA
THIRTY FIGHTER GETTING FARMERS
AND SUPPORT EACH YEAR. THANK
YOU AN ACTUAL LINE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KATHY SHAFFER
FROM SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT-
ONE LAST- REQUEST MODERATOR.
ANYONE ELSE THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF. AB TEN OH NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO
AND WE HAVE NO SUPPORT YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE
FOLLOWING THE SAME PROCEDURES
WE'RE NOW HEARING FROM ANY
OPPOSITION THOUGH THERE IS NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED
FOR A. B. TEN OH NINE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. SEEING NONE
MOVING AN OVERFLOW ROOM. ALSO
SEEING NON MODERATOR MOVING
ONTO TELECONFERENCE. YOU CAN
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY FOLKS
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB TEN OWN NINE AND ALSO
GIVE US AN IDEA HOW MANY MIGHT
BE IN THE QUEUE OF SO. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF BABY
TEN OH NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF AB. TEN
OH NINE. AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE INK YOU'LL MISTER
CHAIR AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FORTY NINE LINES OPEN. I'M
WAITING ON THE- BILL AND I
THINK MANY OF THE WRONG AGENDA.
MA'AM I HAVE I BELIEVE THAT ANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION EITHER
WHERE ARE NOT IN THIS COMMITTEE
OR WERE ALREADY HERE ON
CONSENT- BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT. ARE A
MODERATE OR ANY OTHER FOLKS ON
THE LINE. AGAIN A REMINDER
WE'RE ON EIGHTY- AB TEN OH
NINE. IN OPPOSITION AND THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION INK YOU ALL
RIGHTS ARE BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS- COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
INQUIRIES. MOTIONS ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU-
WHICH TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR CALLED THE EURO. AND
IT WOULD BE A DO PASSED THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS IS
THAT CORRECT. ALL RIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR BORDERS.
YEARS LARGEST HI CENTER TIED OF.
CABALLERO HI EGGMAN HI WHEN AYE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE ALL RIGHT
PUT THIS BILL ON CALL. AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GO TOO FAR SOME
REMEMBER MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE E. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU I'M
NOT MOVING THE STRUCTURE- AND-
MEMBERS- FIRST LET ME THANKS
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE AND FOR REFERENCING
IN THE ANNOUNCES THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WE'VE BEEN
COLLABORATING ON WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. WE'VE MADE MANY
GREAT STRIDES TOWARDS RESOLVING
THE MANY ISSUES AND- THIS BILL
WHICH IS AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
WITH THEIR HELP AND FULLY
EXPECT TO RESOLVE THEM BEFORE
THIS BILL REACHES THE FLOOR.
AND NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL. MY STAFF
BUT JUST RECEIVED A PROPOSED
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THIS
MORNING. AND SO I REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
IT. CLOSELY MYSELF BUT
CERTAINLY DISCUSS ITS
IMPLICATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AND IT DOES THE PARK AN
IMPORTANT WAY FROM THE
DIRECTION WE'RE HEADED. AND
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN SOME
MARKUP. AMENABLE TO A SIMPLER
APPROACH THAT DOES NOT LOOK
BACK AT PRIOR YEARS BUT
INSTEAD. COMPARES BLOOD AND
BLOOD PRODUCTS ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS THAT WOULD SET THE
TRIGGER. BASED ON FOUR
CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS OF
COMMUNITY SOURCES. PRODUCING AS
MUCH. OR MORE THAN. THE CLOTHES
COLONY SOURCES. I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT TAKING AN AMENDMENT RIGHT
NOW THAT WE MAY WANT TO TWEAK
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND SO MY
PREFERENCE. WOULD BE TO
CONTINUE TO INCLUDE YOUR
CONSULTANT IN THE DISCUSSIONS
WITH B. AND P. AND LAND A FULL
AND FINAL SET OF AMENDMENTS. IN
THE NEXT FEW DAYS CONSISTENT
WITH THE MOCK UP. AND ONGOING
DIALOGUE THAT WE'RE HAVING WITH
THE CEMA. ON THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE BILL AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA PET BLOG MATH
BLOOD BANK. FORGET THE
STRAIGHT. OF ONLY BEEN HANDLING
THIS BILL FOR THREE YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA PET BLOOD BANK
MODERNIZATION ACT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS BOTH THE SHORTAGE OF
ANIMAL BLOOD FOR VETERINARY
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE AND PHASE
OUT THE OBSOLETE AND INHUMANE
PRACTICE OF CAPTIVE CLOSED
COLONY CANINE BLOOD BANKS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY AUTHORIZING
LICENSED VETERINARIANS TO
OPERATE COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS
TO PRODUCE AND SELL ANIMAL
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS. THESE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS FOR
ANIMALS ARE SIMILAR TO HUMAN
MODELS IN THAT THEY COLLECT
BLOOD FOR PETS WHOSE OWNERS
VOLUNTARILY CONSENT TO THE
DONATION. CURRENTLY THIS
VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY BASED
APPROACH ISN'T ALLOWED HERE
INSTEAD CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
REQUIRES ANIMAL BLOOD TO COME
FROM SO CALLED CLOSE COLONIES.
THAT KEEP HUNDREDS OF ANIMALS
IN CONFINEMENT FOR YEARS FOR
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF HARVESTING
THEIR BLOOD. MEANWHILE DEMAND
FOR ANIMAL OF BLOOD VASTLY
OUTSTRIPS THE CLOSE QUALITY
SUPPLY AND VETERINARIANS ARE
REGULAR VETERINARIANS ARE
REGULARLY FACED WITH A LACK OF
LIFESAVING PRODUCTS TO PERFORM.
TRANSFUSIONS AND RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO PROVIDES A HUMANE SOLUTION
FOR SOURCING ANIMAL BLOOD WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESSING THE
SUPPLY SHORTAGE AND
ESTABLISHING CONDITIONS TO
EVENTUALLY PHASE OUT CAPTIVE
CLOSE COLONY K. NINE BLOOD
BANKS. MY STAFF AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE C. VMA AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE TRIGGER AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER FOR THE PHASE
OUT OF THE CLOSE CALL IN THE
MODEL TO ENSURE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF BEST PRACTICES. AND MAKE
CRITICAL BLOOD PRODUCTS MORE
WIDELY AVAILABLE OKAY AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO ADDRESSES THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY NINETEEN OF
SB TWO OH TWO. AT THAT TIME A
BY PROVIDING A TRANSITION AWAY
FROM THE USE OF CAPTIVE CLOSE
COLONY CANINE BLOOD BANKS IN
CALIFORNIA. ONLY PHASING THEM
OUT ONCE THE AMOUNT OF DOG
BLOOD COMMUNITY BANKS CELLS
WERE EQUALS. OR EXCEEDS SELL
EITHER EQUALS OR EXCEEDS THE
AMOUNT THE CLOSE CALL ON THE
CELL FOR A PERIOD OF FOUR
CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS. WE'RE
VERY CLOSE TO REACHING
AGREEMENT ON THESE PROVISIONS
OF STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT SENATOR WELL CAN I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
PASSIONATELY NOW FOR THREE
YEARS. AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE APPROACH THAT
VETERINARIANS ANIMAL WELFARE
INTERESTS AND THE AFFECTED
STATE DEPARTMENTS CAN ALL AGREE
WILL PUT CALIFORNIA ON A PATH
TO ETHICALLY SOURCED SAFE. AND
EXPANDED ANIMAL BLOOD SUPPLY.
CALLING IN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL ARE DOCTOR CAN
PULASKI CLINICAL DIRECTOR AT
INSIGHT VETERINARY WELLNESS
CENTER IN EL DORADO HILLS AND I
BELIEVE HERE WITH US IS DR
JEANINE BERGER. SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF RESCUE AND WELFARE
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUR
MODERATOR CAN WE START AND SEE
IF OF IF THEY'RE AVAILABLE I'M
STARTING WITH- CAN PULASKI AND
THEN- JEANINE BERGER- TWO
MINUTES EACH WE'RE TOTAL OF
FOUR. THANK YOU AN AIRLINE
THEY'RE OPEN. HELLO I CAN'T
LAST YEAR AND MY GOOD TO GO YES
SIR. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
BORDERS AND MANY MEMBERS I
CAN'T FIND YOUR DATE AFTER
YEARS OF CORPORATE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TO HELP INCREASE THAT
ASSURE THAT ADEQUATE STATE
SUPPLY AGAIN I'D LIKE FOR
VETERINARY NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO SINCERELY
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR
HIS PERSEVERANCE AND
PERSISTENCE ON THIS ISSUE I
KNOW IT IS A CHALLENGE. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR CAN'T PULL OUT AND I
AM A VETERINARIAN LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA THE CLINICAL
DIRECTOR AND OWNER. INSIGHT
VETERINARY WELLNESS CENTER THE
SMALL ANIMAL HOSPITAL OVER RADO
HILLS PROVIDING PRIMARY CARE IN
TWENTY FOUR HOUR EMERGENCY
CARE. WE CURRENTLY HAVE NINE
VETERINARIANS INCLUDING A FULL
TIME FORTY CRITICAL. PART TIME
INTERNET AND CONTRACTED
CARDIOLOGISTS YOUR- PRIOR TO
OPENING OUR NEW HOSPITAL LAST
YEAR WE ON TO BAND FIELD
HOSPITAL. OKAY TIME GENERAL
PRACTICE. IN THOSE HOSPITALS
ARE NEED FOR BLOOD WAS FAIRLY
RARE AND IF WE DIDN'T NEED IT
WE COULD USUALLY COLLECTED FROM
ONE OF OUR STAFF THAT. WORK IS
MORE CRITICAL YOU'RE REFERRING
TO AN AMERICAN. NOW IT'S AN
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL AND THE
WHOLE NEW BALLGAME. YOU NEVER
KNOW WHEN WE WILL NEED BLOOD OR
BLOOD PRODUCTS. BUT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN WE HAVE MULTIPLE
PETS IN NEED OFTEN REQUIRING
MULTIPLE UNITS. YEAH ONE MASS
REMOVAL SURGERY RECENTLY THAT
ENDED UP NEEDING FOR YOU KNOW
ALL BLOOD ACT RBC. OR YOU KNOW
THE FIVE. AFTER USING IN HOUSE
FILED BY THE UNITED BLOOD
COLLECTED FROM THE TECHNICIANS
DOG WE BORROWED ONE THOUSAND UP
FROM THREE OTHER EMERGENCY
HOSPITAL INCLUDING ONE IN
FAIRFIELD. EFFECTIVELY WIPING
OUT THE BLOOD SUPPLY AND
GREATER SACRAMENTO WHERE. THIS
FORCES US TO MAKE HARD CHOICES
BETWEEN WHICH PATIENTS WILL
LOSE P. BLOOD CLOT. THERE
SIMPLY IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH
BLOOD TO THE PATIENTS WHO NEED.
WELL I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS FOR DOG
CAN FIND THE TO CLOSE POLICY
BLOOD THING BUT BIGGER CONCERNS
RELATED THE AND ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS FOR
PATIENTS. THESE TWO COMPANIES
SIMPLY CANNOT SUPPLY THE NEEDS
OF CRITICALLY ILL AND INJURED
SEVEN CALIFORNIA. THAT IS WHY I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
WHICH WILL ALLOW VETERINARIANS
TO ESTABLISH COMMUNITY BASED
BLOOD BANK. DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE BLOOD AVAILABLE
FOR PATIENTS. IN ADDITION IT
WILL ALLOW US TO IMPORT THESE
PRODUCTS FROM OUT OF STATE AS
LONG AS THEY MEET OUR- THANK
YOU NEED TO BE ASSURED THAT
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS.
COMING FROM ALSO I'M WRAPPING
UP FROM ALL SOURCES REMAIN
STATE SO IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
STANDARD THINK I'D LIKE TO BE
ESTABLISHED TO ENSURE NOT ONLY
ADEQUATE WHY. ALSO THE- I TRULY
HOPE NONE OF YOUR BEST EVER
NEED A TRANSFUSION. BUT IF THEY
WOULD WHAT DO YOU WANT TO KNOW.
WHAT AVAILABLE. RESULT HI. AB
TWELVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH MY ON- MRS BERGER IF YOU
CAN PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO TWO MINUTES. WARNING THAT
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CONFIRMING YOU CAN HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. MY NAME IS DR JEANINE
BERGER AND I'M A LICENSED
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIANS AND
THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
RESCUE AND ANIMAL WELFARE. SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. BROUGH UC DAVIS
I'M BOARD CERTIFIED WITH THE
FOOTBALL THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
FROM ADMITTING IGNORANCE ABOUT
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF ANIMAL
WELFARE. ELEVEN I HAVE OVERSEEN
ASPECTS OF CLINICAL BEHAVIOR
AND WELFARE AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. APERTURA I
WROTE AB EIGHTY TWO TO
MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA THANK A
LOT THANK INDUSTRY. RIGHT NOW
AND THE PUBLIC ARE INCREASE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WELFARE
STATUS STATUS ANIMALS IN
SOCIETY THESE CHANGES HAVE
IMPACTED MOST AREAS OF
VETERINARY PRACTICE INCLUDING
THE K. NINE BUCK BANKING
INDUSTRY. THE CURRENT SITUATION
IN CALIFORNIA IS EGREGIOUSLY
ABOUT. BLOOD DONOR DOCTOR KEPT
CONFINED FOR MONTHS OR YEARS IN
APPALLING CONDITIONS.
FORTUNATELY IN A MOVE THAT
RECOGNIZES THE INTRINSIC NEEDS
OF THESE DOGS MANY BLOOD BANKS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
TRANSITIONED FROM COLD CALL THE
PROGRAM TO COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS THAT COLLECT BLOOD
FROM PRESCREEN. HEALTHY FAMILY
PET WITH ESTABLISHED. AND
SUCCESSFUL PROTOCOLS IN PLACE.
NIERENBERG THE NAY EDUCATE AND
SKILLS TO MODERNIZE IN. IN
WEIGHT THAT UP. SAFE AND HUMANE
WE ARE EAGER TO WORK TOGETHER
AB PROFESSION TO MAKE COMMUNITY
BANK THE STANDARD OF CARE AND
THE COLD COLONY BLOOD BANKS
CAN'T TRANSITION TO COMMUNITY
SOURCING. ASSEMBLY DISCUSSED
THE STATE HAVE THE SPACE AND
CAPACITY TO COLLECT COLLECT
BLOOD. CALIFORNIA STATE LAW I'M
ON FIRST PLAY OUT THE FRAMEWORK
THAT BALANCES THE INTERESTS AND
WELL BEING OF DONOR ANIMALS
RECIPIENT ANIMAL AND
VETERINARIANS WHO NEEDS ACCESS
WITHOUT THE BLOOD SUPPLY. WE
KNOW COMMUNITY BACK BOB THANK
CAN COOPERATE PLEASE SAVE AND
ETHICALLY AS OUT OF
PRACTICALLY. WE ARE OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE CAN SORT OUT THE FINAL
UNRESOLVED ISSUES INCLUDING A
CLEAR AND STATE TRIGGER FOR
THINGS. LIKE GOING INTO A SENSE.
I THINK GOING TO PAY AND BLOCKS
AND BLOCKS. FROM HUMAN RESOURCE
AND DEVELOP OF HELPFUL BEST
PRACTICES AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
HOUR THE BENEFITS OF THE BILL.
ENTERED AND I URGE YOU I'D WITH
THANK SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT- ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SEEING
NONE MOVING TO OVERFLOW- HI
THOSE WISHING TO. SUPPORT OUR
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO SEEING
NONE MODERATELY PLEASE GO ON
TO- TELECONFERENCE Q. AND LET
US KNOW- HOW MANY FOLKS MIGHT
BE IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. AND
MISTER KERR WE HAVE FIVE IN Q.
AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHTS ON
FOLKS IF YOU COULD PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
GREAT THANK YOU OF ALL THE TO
LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SOCKET FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM A
FARMER WAITING. FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. NEXT
MODERATOR CORRECT THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ELIZABETH OR
IT CAN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY AND
OUR THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS STAFF SUPPORTERS AND
PARTNERS TO VOICE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NETWORK WE'LL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
DISAPPEARED MEDICS WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO HAVE A SOME YOU.
FORTY DOLLARS I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE- INFIGHTING.
REPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
WILLIS CALL MODERATOR PLEASE
FOR THOSE WISHING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO ONE LET'S
CALL. THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE EIGHTY TWO.
AND THAT IS THE BIG FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AND WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT WHERE WE GET THIRD LINE
NUMBER. CAN I GET THAT ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR AND SUPPORTS. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE AT NINETY
NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE OF THEM IN WITH A
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING NEARLY
ALL PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ANIMAL
SHELTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
SUPPORT AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
UNLESS THERE ARE MORE FOLKS IN
THE QUEUE MODERATOR WE WILL BE
MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION
ALTHOUGH THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED FOR
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. ANY FOLKS
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
HE'S APPROACHED THE LECTERN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CERTAINLY NOT
OPPOSITION WERE IN THAT AWKWARD
TWEENER POSITION THANK YOU I AM
CRISTINA DO CARMO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE A TWENTY SECONDS
WE HAVE AN APPROVED IF AMENDED
POSITION BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE YOUR- COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR ALL HER HARD
WORK AND THE ANALYSIS AND THEN
CERTAINLY MR BLOOM AND HIS
TEAM. FOR THE VERY ACTIVE
ENGAGEMENT WE HAVE HAD ON THIS
BILL OF THE AMENDMENT PACKAGE
THAT'S IN CIRCULATION RIGHT NOW
GETS US EVER CLOSER TO A
RESOLUTION ON THE BIG ISSUES
SUCH AS THE TRIGGER AND THE
WIND DOWN- ISSUE THAT YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT OF THE EXISTING
COMMERCIAL FACILITIES AND THEN
WE WOULD STILL LIKE TO SEE-
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE BUT AGAIN THAT
LANGUAGE IS ALSO IN CIRCULATION
ON GOING DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND MR
BLOOM- TO THAT END THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
OR BETWEEN HERS. ALL RIGHT
MOVING ON TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM.
SEEING NONE OUR MODERATOR
MOVING IS A TELECONFERENCE ON
ANY FOLKS QUEUED UP TO BE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION- TO AB
TWELVE EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE TO THANK YOU
WILL GO FIRST LINE OF EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOONMR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEFFREY LEE **** LEE ****
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE-
ANIMAL BLOOD BANK- JUST LIKE TO
CLARIFY. THE ONE MISSTATEMENT
THAT I HEARD IN THE TESTIMONY.
HE THAT COLONY DONORS ARE
HEALTHY HAPPY AND WELL CARED
FOR. AND THEIR WELFARE IS
PROTECTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE WHO INSPECTION
ENFORCES PROVISIONS OF THE
FEDERAL ANIMAL WELFARE ACT.
THE- THE TWO COMMENTS I LIKE TO
MAKE AND WE'RE NOT IN OPPOSED
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT. OF
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKING ARE
THAT THE TRIGGER NEEDS TO BE
DYNAMIC. EXTENDED TIME IN THE
PAST. THE WIND DOWN NEEDS TO BE
A GRADUAL NOT GOING OVER A
CLIFF. AND THE AUTHORS
PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO REMOVE
THE REFERENCE SYSTEM AB H. TìM
THE PRIOR COMMITTEE I WOULD
JUST APPRECIATE. RECOGNITION
FROM THE AUTHOR THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE HAPPENING AND UPSET
ABOUT MEMBERS COMING SOONER
THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE PROBABLY HAD YOU-
LINED UP AS IN OPPOSITION- LEAD
SPEAKER- WITH THOSE COMMENTS
BUT MATER MOVING FORWARD. ANY
OTHER. FOLKS IN THE QUEUE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
PLEASE LIMIT TO NAME- POSITION
AND AFFILIATION. THANK YOU AND
AS A REMINDER WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FORTY
NINE YOUR LINES OPEN. I'M AGO
FARMER THAT WAS DISPLACED BY
THE THOMAS FIRE I HAVE WE ARE
MA'AM WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THE
MA'AM I KNOW THAT- WE'VE
ENTERTAINED- YOU'RE RATHER
COLORFUL I QUESTIONS BUT THAT
ITEM WAS ON CONSENT IF I RECALL
IT WAS AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT.
THAT WAS RESOLVED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE MEETING SO-
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT FOR THE
RECORD I THINK FOR THE THIRD
TIME PERHAPS ALL RIGHT ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE QUEUE MODERATOR.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
VETERANS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- NICE TO SEE YOU
MISTER BLOOM I FEAR AND I WAS
AS CHAIR OF AG AND HEARD THIS
BILL. AND HAVE WORKED ON THIS
BILL AND SO I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO GRADUATE THE AUTHOR ON. OF
FINALLY BEING ABLE TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE IT THERE ARE NOT
PEOPLE LINED UP AND DOWN THE
HALLWAYS TO PROTEST THIS BILL
SO. I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL AND I WOULD SUGGEST WOULD
NOT TAKE ANY AMENDMENTS ON THE
FLY HERE AND- AND MAYBE PERHAPS
IN YOUR CLOTHES YOU CAN ADDRESS
GOING FORWARD- WOULD WHAT YOU
AGREED TO WORK ON THIS BILL BUT
AND I WOULD. SUGGEST WE TRY TO
DO NO AMENDMENTS NOW. AND AGAIN
JUST CAN GRADUATION TO BE ABLE
TO BRING ALL THE SIDES TOGETHER
I KNOW THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
YOU IT SOUNDS LIKE OR HAVE A-
PATH FORWARD. THAT WILL. THAT
WILL REASONABLY CLOSE OUT THE
CLOTHES COLONIES AS MUCH AS OUR
SUPPLY GOES UP AND I THINK
THAT'S A AN OUTCOME THAT WOULD.
THAT WOULD ALL BE VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH THANK YOU. Q.
SERVICE. AND WANT TO THANK THAT
IS SELLING THEM FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA FOR
MANY YEARS. AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR WELCOME HIS EFFORTS-
THAT PARALLEL WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE. TRY TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
THIS AREA VERY SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT I. I THINK-
CENTER EGGMAN NONTON PROBABLY
SAID IT BEST I DO REMEMBER IT'S
ON THE FLY- I WOULD LIKE TO
HOWEVER- MAKE CERTAIN THAT- THE
CONSULTANT- IF YOU WOULD TO.
QUICKLY IDENTIFY THE ONES THAT
WE WOULD. SUGGEST ARE DOWN THE
ROAD. THOMAS I KNOW THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A MOVING TARGET.
JUST IT JUST REMINDS- THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU- I MY
SUGGESTION AMENDMENTS IN THE
BILL TALKS ABOUT REMOVING AT
201-820-1920 TWENTY THREE YEARS
WITH AVERAGE THE AMOUNT OF
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS THAT
WERE SOLD IF THIS IS- TRIGGERS
IT PULLED SO YOU KNOW TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THOSE NUMBERS ARE A
LITTLE STALE SO. MY SUGGESTION
BY ANNOUNCES WAS TO GO BACK
JUST THE THREE PREVIOUS YEARS-
IF YOU'LL SEE- ON THE- ANALYSIS
PAGE I THINK IT'S SEVEN US THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD
ASSOCIATION HAVE LINED UP FOR
BOTH POINTS OF WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY
INCORPORATED IN THAT SO- THEY
HAVE COMMITTED TO KEEPING ME
INVOLVED SO I CAN KEEP YOU ALL
INVOLVED ON THIS ISSUE AS IT
MOVES FORWARD ALL RIGHT. AND I
WANT TO ASK YOU TO ADOPT THOSE
BUT PLEASE TAKE THOSE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS INTO THE NEXT-
EVOLUTION OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IF YOU WOULD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND FINALIZED
STATEMENTS YES- BONTA ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE WE ARE LOOKING
AT A DIFFERENT TO A METRIC THAT
STUFF FOUR CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS
BUT OF COURSE- YOUR- STAFF- A
CONSULTANT WILL BE INCLUDED IN
IN THAT IN. THAT DISCUSSION-
THE WAS ALSO- I REQUEST FROM-
OUR DOCTOR TO CAIRO OF CDMA-
FOR US TO. CONSIDER DISCUSSING
THE- ADVISORY COMMITTEE ISSUE
AND WILL BE DOING- THAT WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO DISCUSSION ON
THAT- AND- FINALLY- MR LEE ****
SAID- I MENTIONED- THE AV H. T.
M. REFERENCE BOB THAT IN FACT
IS IN THE MOCK UP THAT WE
PRESENTED. TO TO THE COMMITTEE
ON MONDAY AND WE'RE INTENDING
TO- INCLUDE DEBT THOSE
AMENDMENTS- WHEN WE GET TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT
ANYTHING ELSE FURTHER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE THE- MOTION FRONT
CENTER EGGMAN TO- PROVE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO I BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE IT. DO. PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST. I'M AND WE
WERE TO THE CAN ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONALS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS THAT ACCURATE.
WHERE IT WOULD BE THE SECOND
ONE I BELIEVE IT'S JUST TO DO
PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
BE- WE GO THROUGH THE- ARTS OF
DO PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONALS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND THE BARGES ALL RIGHT
FORGES I. EVER TAUGHT OF.
SENATE CABALLERO. HI SENATE
EGGMAN RIGHT AND EVEN I CENTER
GLAZER FIVE GLAZER AYE ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL BUT- THE CALL IS GOING TO
BE LIFTED AND RICK RELATIVE
SHORT ORDER. BILLS DO WE HAVE
ON THE CALL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WE HAVE ALL OF THEM
INCLUDING THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ALL RIGHT AND WE HEARD IF. ONE
OF OUR COMPATRIOTS IS ON HER
WAY I THINK SHE WAS PRESENTING
A BILL. OKAY WE GO THROUGH THE
ON GO CALL SO WE CAN ALL WE ALL
GO TO YOU DON'T THE WAY BEHIND-
YOU WANT TO START IS OFF. START
WITH. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTING OF ITEMS FOREIGN
SEVEN FIVE FOUR AND SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX TO THREE AND A. B.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. AND WE'RE
MISSING- CENTER CABALLERO I
HAVE YOUR I. CENTER GLAZER. HI
THE BILL HAS EVERYBODY ON IT
RIGHT FOLLOW. OR AB FORTY FIVE
SENATOR AG- SOMEONE ASK YOUR
CREASE DO PASS- BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AND CENTER TACO
SARAH CABALLERO CAREER I CENTER
GLAZER THERE GLAZER BY. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B- FIVE
THIRTY FIVE DO PASSED BUT
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. SERRET TADA. THE TWO
WERE MISSING ON THAT ONE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
FIFTY BY THE APPROVED WHAT DO
PASS- AS AMENDED BUT FIRST THE
MAN REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SARAH TITHER.
CENTER EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE
TICKER. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB SEVEN ONE NINE- WAS DUE
PASSED BUT RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT WOULD BE SAID HER TADO.
THE SERVICE ON THAT ONE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THAT'S
CONSENT AFTER THE FOLLOWING
NUMBER EIGHT AB ONE ZERO ZERO
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. I
WAS TO PASS BUT REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AND HER TADO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM WAS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. I BELIEVE
THAT WAS. CALL CENTER TIME.
THAT WAS IT WHEN WE RECESSED
FOR FIVE MINUTES AND GIVE A-
THE CENTER UP TO COME.
BILLS
FOR OUR COLLEAGUE YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM ONE AB
FORTY FIVE DO PASSED BUT COULD
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER TITLE I
TITLE II. WITHOUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE-
DO PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
CENTER HER TADO HI. TYRA. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. IS TO PASS-
EIGHTY THREE FIFTY TWO PASSES A
MINUTE BUT FIRST AMEND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER TADO I.
TAUGHT IN HIGH. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
ONE NINE DO PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER HER TADO.
I DO I. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO ZERO
NINE DO PASSED THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER TADO. FOR
TITLE II. AND BY NUMBER NINE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO- DO PASSED
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CENTER TYLER.
ADELINE ALTHOUGH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO YEAH COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US I WATER INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA.
SENATE AG IS ADJOURNED.